bonjour à tous la semaine dernière
Benoît amont a été auditionné par la
mission d'information sénatoriale sur
les rythmes scolaires objectif des
sénateurs évaluer la mise en place de la
réforme qui a été initiée par Vincent
payon le passage de la la semaine de 4
jours et demi qui a déjà débuté dans
4000 communes en septembre 2013 et qui
devra s'élargir à l'ensemble de la
France en septembre
2014 la semaine dernière Benoît amamont
nouveau ministre de l'Éducation a
annoncé et bien un décret complémentaire
assouplissant la réforme avec notamment
la possibilité et bien de regrouper
toutes les activités préscolaires dans
une demi-journée par semaine et
d'éventuelles journées à l'école de plus
de 6h mais voilà hier et bien nous avons
appris que le Conseil supérieur de
l'éducation qui rassemble et bien des
représentants de parents d'élèves et des
représentants de l'éducation national
n'avait pas apporté son accord à ce
décret complémentaire voilà tout de
suite retour à cette audition qui s'est
tenue la semaine dernière le 30 avril au
Sénat monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs nous
procédons aujourd'hui à la dernière
audition dans le cadre de nos travaux
sur la mission commune d'information
dont le thème c'est la réforme des
rythme scolaire monsieur le ministre
soyez bienvenu au Sénat un grand merci à
vous un grand merci de la part de
l'ensemble des membres de cette mission
commune d'information les 33 membres de
votre présence d'avoir accepté cette
audition puisque nous sommes qui
quasiment à la fin de nos
travaux avec le Premier ministre
Monsieur Manuel Vals vous avez décidé
d'assouplir le cadre réglementaire pour
qu'il s'adapte aux expérimentations du
terrain en ouvrant la possibilité
d'expérimenter des rythmes scolaires
plus souples à condition qu'il soit
conçu pour l'intérêt de l'enfant je me
réfère à un article paru dans Le Monde
le 25 avril
2014 votre objectif qui est également le
nôtre monsieur le ministre c'est de
permettre à tous les enfants quel que
soient leurs origines sociales de bien
apprendre de mieux apprendre à l'école
et donc de pouvoir réussir nous
partageons totalement cet objectif vous
affirmez également dans la même
interview que les aménagement euh que
nous propose que vous proposez répondent
aux difficultés d'organisation qui vous
ont été remontées par certains acteurs
locaux je vous cite hein or monsieur le
ministre la mission commune
d'information sur la mise en œuvre des
rythmes scolaires a été créé en octobre
2013 madame Cartron en est le rapporteur
moi-même la présidente avec les 33
membres de la mission commune
d'information nous avons procédé à une
longue série d'auditions 12 séances de 3
à 4hes chacune de novembre 2013 à avril
2014 cette phase nous a permis
d'entendre nous tous les acteurs tous
les acteurs de la réforme l'objectif est
de répertorier les difficultés les
blocages et proposer des solutions le
cas échéant je regrette à ce jour que
nous n'ayons pas eu le temps de vous de
présenter plutôt ce rapport j'aurais
souhaité le le présenter d'ici le mois
de mars cela n'a pas été possible parce
qu'il nous fallait encore introduire des
déplacements mais je je pense qu'il il
aurait été opportun de de le présenter
plus tôt cela aurait permis évidemment
monsieur le ministre à à vous-même et à
vos services de vous en inspirer
largement pour la mise en œuvre de du
décret modificatif enfin de
l'assouplissement que vous
proposez nous avions également demandé
dès le mois de février à votre
prédécesseur monsieur payon de de
répondre à un ensemble enfin de tenir
compte d'un ensemble de d'une dizaine de
questions qui formulaiit en fait en fait
l'ensemble des des problématiques que
nous avions pu mettre disons mettre en
évidence et nous n'avions
malheureusement aucune réponse je
voulais vous remercier Monsieur le
Ministre puisque nous avons obtenu ces
réponses il y a il y a 2 jours de cela
et j'ai la faiblesse de croire que
peut-être quelques-unes de ces questions
et des réponses que vous avez pu y
apporter ont pu vous aider à élaborer
les les assouplissements que vous nous
proposez voilà les propos introductifs
euh monsieur le ministre je vais vous je
vais vous donner la parole ensuite au
niveau de la méthodologie madame le
rapporteur vous posera des questions
auquel je vous convierai à à faire des
réponses et ensuite je donnerai la
parole à l'ensemble de mes collègues
pour un échange question réponse si vous
en êtes d'accord monsieur le ministre
parfait la parole est à
vous madame la
Présidente merci beaucoup madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
vous avez dit et je serais évidemment
très
attentif au travail qui a été le votre
vous avez dit avoir pu prendre le pou de
tous les acteurs sur la question des
rythmes scolaires je vous je reconnais
volontiers que ceux avec lesquels j'ai
été en contact pour l'essentiel étent
ceux qui n'étaient pas contents et pour
ce qui me concerne j'ai davantage parler
à mon initiative en particulier à un
certain nombre de maires d'élu qui euh
m'ont manifesté des difficultés
euh la plupart du temps je le dis de de
très bonne foi des difficultés des
questions des interrogations sur la
portée des assouplissements que nous
envisagions euh la réalité du terrain
qui était la l'heure la mémoire des
expérimentations qu'ils avaient pu
mettre en œuvre avant la réforme d'Arcos
parce qu'il y en existait de nombreuses
qui ont été rendues euh difficile voire
impossible par la réforme d'Arcos il y
avait là des des questions qui étaient
des questions légitimes que que j'ai
voulu écouter je voudrais revenir
cependant et vous l'avez évoqué
vous-même au point qui fait consensus
entre
nous c'est que l'école française et
notamment l'école primaire ne remplit
plus sa mission aussi bien que nous le
souhaiterions tous en matière
d'apprentissage fondamentaux et cela se
mesure à l'entrée en 6e par une
dégradation des capacités qui sont
celles de nos enfants à maîtriser les
apprentissages fondamentaux en matière
de calcul en matière d'écrit d'oral de
lecture et c'est là une difficulté qui
est une difficulté qui explique plus
tard le décrochage qui explique que
notre pays soit recordman dans l'OCDE en
matière d'inégalité
sociale le Premier ministre avait évoqué
dans sa déclaration de politique
générale combien le discours politique
pouvait s'apparenter aux yeux de
beaucoup de Français à une langue morte
mais quand la promesse républicaine
d'égalité est aussi communément partagée
par nous tous et irrigue régulièrement
nos discours politiques et que dans
l'école de la répu public se niche une
une reproduction sociale aussi forte des
inégalité sociale aussi dur qu'elles
font de nous le pays recordman d'Europe
en
matière de d'inégalité sociale au sens
où l'origine sociale s'attache au destin
scolaire des enfants c'est là une
question qui est posée évidemment à tous
les élus de la République que nous
sommes et au premier chef au ministre de
l'Éducation le travail qui est le mien
il d'abord se concentre sur le temps
scolaire et euh mon prédécesseur avait
eu occasion à juste tiritre de le
rappeler euh quand il était ministre de
l'Éducation nous considérons aujourd'hui
qu'au regarde du nombre de jours
travailler et scolarisé au regarde de ce
qui était le la lourdeur des semaines
nous n'offrons pas aux enfants de la
République les meilleures conditions en
terme d'apprentissage nous n'offrons pas
aux professeurs des écoles les
meilleures conditions pour transmettre
des connaissances et pour permettre qu'à
l'issue de l'école primaire nos enfants
disposent des des capacités optimales
pour chacun d'entre eux selon leur
différence leur qualité leur sens de
l'effort les meilleures chances de
pouvoir posséder disposer de ces
apprentissages fondamentaux c'est la
raison pour laquelle à partir du
consensus qui avait été bâti notamment
sous le précédent gouvernement et sous
l'impulsion du ministre Luc chattel nous
avons souhaité mettre en place sous la
forme d'un décret une organisation du
temps scolaire pensé autour de 9
demi-journées et d'un principe
on va dire magistral en quelque sorte
celui de CIN matinées travaillé cinq
matinées car nous savons que les pic de
vigilance ce sont ont lieu entre 9h et
11h le matin et que ce sont les moments
où nos enfants sont les plus concentrés
donc les plus en capacité de pouvoir
apprivoiser et ensuite maîtriser ces
apprentissages fondamentaux autour de de
cela et de cette réforme qui s'est
engagée qui a connu une
première h année de mise en œuvre avec
près de 4000 communes
1300000 écoliers qui aujourd'hui sont au
nouveau rythme scolaire nous avons pu
avoir là non pas un théâtre
d'expérimentation parce ce n'était pas
l'objectif mais euh euh une mesure aussi
une évaluation du bien fondé euh d'un
certain nombre de nos choix euh moi il
ne m'appartient pas de dire euh quand on
me dit ça ne se passe mal si c'est
légitime ou pas si les arguments sont de
bonne ou de mauvaise foi
quand un professeur me dit c'est pas
bien pas à moi de dire est-ce qu'il est
de bonne foi ou pas quand un parent
d'élève me dit ça m'a bouleversé ma
journée vous ne vous rendez pas compte
monsieur le ministre c'est pas à moi de
dire si c'est bien fondé ou pas il
m'appartient de tenir compte de la
réalité et de ne pas être dans le dénis
et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'au-delà des résistances qui ont pu
être exprimées par un certain nombre de
professeurs sur le fait que ce mercredi
matin qu'il fallait travailler modifier
leur propre organisation de vie leur
propre l'articulation entre leur vie
professionnelle et leur vie personnelle
sur la nouvelle organisation que cela
supposé pour certains parents d'élèves
et bien au-delà de ça ce qui est
intéressant dans cette première année et
qui se vérifiera je l'espère sur le
temps long la particularité de
l'éducation vous le savez bien Madame la
Présidente et Madame la rapporteur c'est
qu'elle s'accommode assez mal de ce
qu'est l'ire du temps parce que l'air du
temps c'est le court terme et qu'il est
très difficile en matière d'éducation
d'avoir des résultats au moin le mois
mais ce que nous disent les professeurs
qui ont expérimenté
la nouvelle organisation du temps
scolaire c'est que sans nier les
difficultés pour eux-mêmes et l'embarras
que cela a créé pour certains d'entre
eux ils reconnaissent pour leur immense
majorité que l'impact sur les enfants
sur la concentration et notamment la
concentration des élèves qui ont le plus
de difficultés au départ l'impact est
positif alors on est qu' au terme d'une
première année on aurait pu aussi
construire un panel de ceux qui avant la
réforme d'Arcos avaient déjà des une
organisation du temps scolaire assez
semblable il en existe beaucoup coup à
gauche comme à droite et moi je me
réjouis de voir que sur ces sujets-là on
entend les prises de parole vont au-delà
des des des des des réflexes partisans
comme on dit mais on a là une première
mesure qui est tout à fait positive de
cette organisation du temps scolaire
nous sommes maintenant dans la seconde
phase qui est celle de la généralisation
qu'avonsnous voulu faire dans cette
seconde phase tenir compte
euh d'une situation qui est celle de
communes qui n'ont ni la même taille
ni la même expérience en matière
d'organisation du temps scolaire ni les
mêmes moyens parfois d'organiser les
activités péréscolaires ni le même
contexte une commune de Montagne ce
n'est pas une commune de du futur Grand
Paris ou métropolitaine ou je regarde
quelques-uns d'entre vous comme je
connais des visages je vais citer
probablement des des des villes de vos
territoires mais on a là des des
différences qui sont des différences
assez évidentes nous avons voulu faire
en sorte que sur la base du décret
initial qui organise en quelque sorte le
droit commun les 9U demi-journées nous
puissions dans un décret
complémentaire mettre en place des
expérimentations qui
soi plus adapté à des réalités de
terrain que nous avons croisé
suffisamment régulièrement pour que le
cadre réglementaire s'adapte à ces
expérimentations et pas que ces
expérimentations utiles sace devant un
cadre réglementaire jugé trop strict je
m'explique il y avait je prends
l'exemple d'pin ù monsieur eininrich qui
est maire d'Épinal a une expérience
considérable en matière d'organisation
du temps scolaire nous disait je veux
aujourd'hui avoir une organisation qui
poursuit à mes yeux le même objectif que
vous l'intérêt de l'enfant elle ne
rendre pas tout à fait dans le cadre de
ce du du décret initial peut-on par un
assouplissement qui est celui que nous
allons permettre notamment le fait de
d'alléger davantage la semaine en
faisant en sorte d'allonger les vacances
scolaires ce qui est ce qui va être de
réduire les vacances scolaires si
j'allonge les vacances scolaires en
réduisant la semaine je vais être
extrêmement populaire auprès d'un
certain nombre de de jeunes enfants je
crains que je sois moins mais donc
d'alléger la semaine évidemment en en
faisant en sorte que l'année scolaire
elle s'allonge et qu'on réduise les les
vacances scolaires en permettant cela
nous avons là une forme nouvelle
d'organisation du temps scolaire qui
respecte toujours le principe qui est
celui des cinq matinées successives
c'est-à-dire selon tous les arguments
scientifiques ce que nous disent les
Chron biologiste la lutte contre la
désynchronisation qui est la plus fatale
aux apprentissages fondamentaux sur
lesquels tous les experts aujourd'hui
sentendre le deuxième assouplissement
c'est la possibilité et là ça parle
notamment à des mares de villes de
taille moyenne ou de petites villes
notamment dans des intercommunalités où
on a besoin de l'intercommunalité pour
mutualiser les moyens c'est la
possibilité de rassembler l'ensemble du
temps périscolaire donc je rappelle
qu'il est
facultatif
donc je rappelle qu'il est facultatif
mais de le rassembler sur une même
demi-journée non pas un matin mais une
après-midi de façon là permettre que des
intervenants qui peuvent être les mêmes
sur une intercommunalité puissent le
mardi aller sur la commune x le jeudi
sur la commune y et le lundi sur la
commune Z le cas échéant le vendredi sur
la commune a bref l'objectif est là
d'alléger les coûts des activités
périscolaires par la mutualisation cet
assouplissement qui est dans le s
nouveau évidemment répond d'ors et déjà
à des situations extrêmement
nombreuses voilà ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui principalement dans le
décret une disposition ne figure pas
dans le décret parce qu'elle cela ne se
justifia pas mais dans la circulaire qui
accomagne ce texte et qui sera qui n'est
qu'un projet
soumis en comité technique et en au CSE
la semaine
prochaine j'ai voulu que l'on prenne
compte qu'on tienent qu'on prenne en
compte pardon euh plus précisément la
situation des écoles maternelles où euh
euh la distinction parfois entre le
temps périscolaire et le temps scolaire
euh sur une petite section par exemple
apparaît pas évidente euh pour tout le
monde la réalité c'est qu'elle l'est
pour le professeur des écoles parce
qu'il fait pas le même métier que celui
ou celle qui viendra organiser le
tempérie scolaire qu'il a des objectifs
euh en terme d'acquisition euh de de
connaissance de compét pour les enfants
et qui se juge sur tout le temps de la
maternelle cela étant dit sur les temps
calmes les temps de sommeil pour les
petites sections les temps d'activités
nous avons voulu que les lieux dans
lesquels s'organisent les activités
périscolaires que soi clarifié ces
distinctions entre le temps périscolaire
et et le temps scolaire et je veux dire
tout de suite peut-être que j'anticipe
sur une question mais on m'a posé la
question et puis je je pense que je vais
vous inviter à me m'enoser après mais je
vais répondre au moins à celle-là par
anticipation on m'a dit mais pourquoi
est-ce que dans l'assouplissement vous
ne sortiriez pas l'école maternelle
parce que c'est plus compliqué de
l'école primaire et je me suis dit alors
pardon de toujours tenter de parler de
soi quand on parle d'éducation
nationale et j'observe que c'est il faut
surtout pas le faire mais je vais en
disant ça je vais évidemment rompre avec
le principe que je souhaite voir
s'appliquer à tous mais pourquoi je dis
ça parce que c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
je suis très frappé ce sera mon dernier
mot avant de vous donner de revenir à la
maternelle du fait que nous avons avec
Monsieur Chatel puis monsieur payon
commencé ce débat autour de l'intérêt de
l'enfant du temps
scolaire puis sont monté dans le débat
des questions qui ne sont pas
illégitimes et je le dis tout de suite
qui étent porté par les professeurs les
parents d'élèves les maires et qui nous
ont amené à très vite non plus parler du
temps scolaire mais du temps
périscolaire et qui aujourd'hui
concentre des difficultés de financement
parfois d'organisation parfois de la
part des des maires mais je voudrais que
on revienne aussi au sens et à
l'objectif de cette réforme confronté à
ce que sont les échecs parfois il n'y a
pas que ça heureusement l'école elle
fonctionne quand même bien le collège et
le lycée pour des millions de nos no de
de jeunes adultes adolescents ou élèv
mais il y a aujourd'hui une réalité de
la reproduction sociale et de
l'enracinement des inégalités à l'école
mais il y a personne pour parler à la
place de celles et ceux pour qui nous
faisons la réforme sauf leurs parents le
professeurs et et et les mairres mais je
crois qu'il faut qu'on s'attache
vraiment à ce que s'il y a
assouplissement à travers un décret qui
organise les expérimentations et les
dérogations on ne remet pas en cause que
sera le progrès incontestable d'une
organisation du temps scolaire qui
permette une synchronisation des rythmes
dont on sait bien nous-même comme
adultes que ces rythmes nous vivons avec
nous avons nos propres rythmes de
sommeil et à partir du moment où pour
des tout petits on les bouleverse on les
bouleverse trop règ trop régulièrement
ça perturbe objectivement leur
conditions d'apprentissage je reviens à
la maternelle pour vous dire moi qui
suis papa d'une petite fille qui sort de
maternelle pour aller en primaire et qui
d'une autre petite fille qui rentre en
maternelle je suis dans cette situation
des familles françaises qui ont deux
enfants devont être très nombreux ou qui
en général ces enfants se font dans un
intervalle de 2 à 3 ans vont se
retrouver avec un enfant maternel et un
enfant en primaire si nous pensons
l'organisation du temps scolaire en mat
distinct du temps scolaire en
primaire le désordre ou la
désorganisation supplémentaire que cela
induira on introduira pour des familles
il est aussi réel et je je pense que il
faut quand même que l'on regarde la
situation telle qu'elle est vécue par
celles et ceux qui accompagnent leurs
enfants le matin mais aussi viennent les
chercher en fin de journée et qui ont
besoin d'un peu aussi d'homogénéité dans
l'organisation du temps scolaire ce qui
ne m'amène pas à dire et je le précise
que la maternelle c'est forcément pareil
que le primaire je pense que c'est nous
devons tenir compte d'un certain nombre
de spécificités elles seront notées dans
la circulaire qui accompagnera le décret
mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas
aujourd'hui finalement se dire qu'on
pourrait régler le problème en se disant
nouvelle organisation des rythmes pour
le primaire mais le maternel on pourrait
s'en passer ou on s'en passera et on
verra bien quand ça ira mieux ou je ne
sais
pas à quelle échéance voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire par anticipation
j'évoque cette question parce que j'ai
les oreilles pleines des questions des
interrogations des invitations des
propositions de bon nombre d'élus je
terminerai en disant j'ai essayé dans
depuis ma nomination de de prendre
l'initiative de nombreux
contacts avec évidemment les
associations
d'élus de grande villes des mers des
petites villes des villes rurales des
des mes ruraux
h de de d'interroger des maires qui
publiquement ont exprimé leurs réserves
sur cette réforme de voir de quelle
manière avec eux nous pouvions résoudre
des difficulté qu'il posait je crois que
nous sommes arrivés et nous arriverons à
des résultats tout à fait
probants mais je suis évidemment tout à
fait disposé à évoquer avec vous toutes
les questions y compris les plus
difficiles autour de la mise en œuvre de
cette réforme mais je crois qu'il faut
qu'elle s'applique en 2014 je l'ai dit
et le Premier ministre en est convaincu
aussi et qu'elle s'applique pour que
nous généraliser et mettre en œuvre un
nouvelle organisation du temps scolaire
dont je suis convaincu comme vous aussi
je le crois puisque vous partagiez ce
consensus en tout cas ce point du
consensus avec moi qu'elle est dans
l'intérêt d'abord de nos
enfants merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre merci d'avoir été concis bref
cela nous laissera un petit peu plus de
temps pour l'échange je donne
immédiatement la parole à madame le
rapporteur pour les pour ses
questions merci madame la Présidente et
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
exposé qui donc introduit un certain
nombre de questions et d'autres qui vont
être le reflet de de nos auditions
puisque comme l'a dit madame la
Présidente nous nous sommes livrés à un
travail
d'investigation très je dirais très
sérieux très approfondi qui a demandé du
temps ce qui explique pourquoi notre
rapport sera rendu le 14 mai donc nous
nous essaions d'ailleurs que ce rapport
puisse porter des préconisations utiles
à tous alors je vais d'abord embrayer
sur votre premier point qui est le
décret d'assouplissement que vous avez
évoqué et vous signaler donc quelque
chose nous moi j'ai très bien compris et
nous avons très bien compris que votre
décret
d'assouplissement répondait à la fois à
des cas particuliers c'est-à-dire des
expérimentations antérieures qui ne se
retrouvait pas dans le cadre contraint
du décret payon ou des situations tout à
fait particulières en particul de
mutualisation et visant à une exigence
de qualité par rapport aux activités
proposées néanmoins je vous fait part
nous étions lundi en Gironde à la
rencontre de nombreux Maes et donc je
vous fais part de d'une remontée unanime
malheureusement de tous les maires que
nous avons rencontré il y a eu
incompréhension par rapport à votre
décret c'est-à-dire que les maires ont
compris que ce décret était un décret
nouveau qui se substituait au décret
payon et que donc tous ceux qui étaient
partis c'est-à-dire je parle de maire
qui était parti en 2013 avec une
organisation bien évidemment qui n'avait
absolument pas évoquer l'hypothèse d'un
après-midi entier libéré euh à la fois
sur la pression aussi de parents ou
d'enseignants qui n'ont pas non plus
compris le message redemande la
réécriture total du projet éducatif
territorial tel qu'il fonctionne depuis
un an et tel qu'il fonctionne bien donc
là je vous interroge et je vous
sollicite aussi pour que vous puissiez
apporter une parole forte parce que il y
a aujourd'hui une incompréhension
difficulté de communication de lecture
et donc l'inquiétude et les collègues
qui partageaient avec moi la la
visite ont entendu les maires dire mais
il faut tout remettre à plat et refaire
repartir à zéro alors que aujourd'hui ça
fonctionne mais donc première c'est une
remarque mais plus aussi une question
pour que vous puissiez bien repréciser
l'esprit de l'esprit de de de ce décret
alors ensuite par rapport au auditions
que nous avons mené ici et
donc je voudrais vous
interroger par rapport au rôle de votre
administration et de en particulier
l'encadrement parce que sur le terrain
nous est souvent
remonté un sentiment des MRES d'abandon
seul
face souvent aux parents d'élèves et aux
enseignants les mairres ne se retrouvant
pas accompagnés par les éducation
nationale et ne se sentant pas armé pour
répondre à un certain nombre de
questions parce qu'il n'était pas
suffisamment au fait des des problèmes
donc les maires ont eu un sentiment
justement parfois d'impuissance et de se
sentir
balloté parce que pas suffisamment
accompagné et épaulé donc je crois qu'il
y a là une demande en
particulier pour tous ceux qui vont
démarrer là là en 2014 septembre et qui
sont moins volontaires que je dirais les
maires de la de la première vague euh je
crois que au vu de l'expérience de la
première vague il y a un besoin de
mobilisation des forces de l'éducation
nationale parce que comme vous l'avez
dit c'est une réforme éducation
nationale sur le fond c'est-à-dire ça
vise à améliorer les conditions
d'apprentissage de l'enfant donc il faut
je crois que l'éducation nationale
trouve sa place euh le troisième point
qui et dans le même temps euh par
rapport à l'éducation nationale elle a
un rôle d'accompagnateur elle a un rôle
aussi de de rassurer rassurer les maires
parce que les maires sous des pressions
diverses et variées et puis les maires
ont aussi l'habitude de vouloir faire
bien les choses ils ont eu l'impression
que la barre était très haute et on n
pas su les rassurer de leur dire que
c'était un projet en construction et en
élaboration et que la première mouture
et la première mise en place ne devait
pas viser la perfection à tout prix donc
là encore être rassuré par rapport aux
critiques qu'ils ont pu vivre après de
la part de paror ou de la part
d'enseignants et être accompagné dans
cette expression que c'est un projet qui
va se construire sur les 3 ans qui va
s'amender qui va s'enrichir mais que on
n'est pas obligé et puis c'est c'est
valable je crois pour tout dans
l'éducation nationale euh ou pour une
situation d'élèves on n'est pas obligé
d'être dans la perfection dès euh la
première mouture du travail rendu à
condition qu'on soit dans l'esprit et
dans la volonté ça c'est aussi un point
qui nous a beaucoup remonté alors
ensuite bien évidemment il y a les
problèmes des taux d'encadrement et là
on touche c'est pas euh vraiment
l'éducation nationale mais là nous avons
euh Jeunesse et Sport et nous avons là
une grande confusion par rapport à la
reconnaissance de la qualification des
intervenants et par rapport au taux
d'encadrement je précise par rapport à
la qualification des intervenants
aujourd'hui il y a une nomenclature qui
en fait valide personnel qualifié s'il
possède le BAFA or de nombreux maires
ont fait appel dans l'organisation
desétapes à des intervenants
extérieur qui ont des compétences
éminemment reconnues c'est nous avons eu
des cas nous sommes allés sur le terrain
une ancienne institutrice qui a fait un
diplôme d'herboristerie et qui fait un
atelier autour des plantes et de la
nature qui est considéré comme non
qualifié parce qu'elle n'a pas le BAFA
ce qui après déclenche en chaîne un non
accompagnement financier de la CAF et là
des exemples les professeurs par exemple
d'école de musique qui interviennent
dans le cadre d'étapes sont considérés
comme non qualifiés parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le BAFA donc il y a là une
incompréhension bien sûr la CAF accepte
un taux de 50 % de non qualifié mais par
rapport au Mair ils sont mis en
difficulté par rapport à la présentation
de leur projet à la population parce que
ce qui apparaît c'est qu'il travaillent
avec 50 % de non qualifiés donc ça
affaibli la qualité de leur projet donc
là
nous avons je crois il y a un travail à
faire pour
élargir cette cette nomenclature de
qualification qui rebondit en chaîne sur
après l'octroit et le financement des
financements de la CAF alors nous en
venons à la CAF là je suis obligé de
vous dire que le constat est
unanime donc que voilà la brisante dit
je c'est catastrophique c'est limite
catastrophique c'est c'est-à-dire que le
constat aujourd'hui de ce que nous avons
entendu c'est que de manière la totalité
des maères ruraux ont renoncé à
constituer le dossier parce que le choc
de simplification n'est pas arrivé
jusqu'à la CAF voilà donc là nous sommes
je vous donne l'exemple
concret dans une ville
moyenne
pardon oui même des grandes villes à
race ne ver ont
renoncé pas dans les petites vir dans
une ville là de taille moyenne donc je
vais parler de mon département Libourne
où il y a 17 écoles il faut faire 17
dossier un par école voilà ensuite il
faut tenir une comptabilité journalière
de la présence des enfants au
tap donc cela
mobilise des personnels
municipaux pour arriver à constituer un
dossier devant lequel les maires
renonce sauf dans des grandes grandes
mairies avec une organisation compétente
orors derrière c'est 54 € quand même qui
tombe et ce n'est pas neutre par rapport
à l'accompagnement financier donc je ne
vous cache pas que nous avons auditionné
par deux fois la CAF pour essayer de
bien
comprendre nous avions sans doute une
capacité d'attention limitée parce que
nous aurions peut-être besoin d'une
troème séance mais
je crois que nous préférons
solliciter c'était peut-être un problème
de rythme peut-être mais du coup
monsieur le ministre nous sollicitons
votre aide parce que là il y a il y a un
vrai souci il y a une vraie difficulté
qui nous amène donc bien évidemment
à je crois au trè
problème auquel les maires sont
confrontés c'est bien sûr le financement
et cette grande incertitude parce
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple je redis
aussi les maires nous disent on a besoin
d'être accompagné mais ils ont besoin
aussi d'une perspective or aujourd'hui
et là je reprends l'exemple concret d'h
hier la cfibourne a dit moi je peux rien
dire parce que comme le le ministre a
changé le décret on sait plus ce qu'on
doit faire voilà donc avec ça ça n'aide
pas mais est aussi mise en cause donc le
fond d'amorçage qui a été bien
évidemment euh très apprécié la première
année très apprécié pour l'année
2014-215 qui s'ouvre mais pour
lesquels on comprend il y avait d'abord
une finalité un fond d'amorçage il y
avait des choses à mettre en place qui
coûte plus les premières années que les
autres mais cela n'exclut pas par
rapport à une demande de mère de
continuer à pouvoir avoir un
accompagnement euh alors dans tous les
élus que nous avons auditionnés qui peut
être dégressif qui peut être modulé tout
ça c'est à construire mais je pense que
ce que les mères attendent c'est un un
signe leur disant une fois encore qu'ils
pourront être accompagné euh dans cette
grande réforme qui est la réforme des
rythmes ensuite je dirais euh un dernier
mot sur la maternelle bien évidemment
euh je pense qu'il faut faire passer le
message que les rythmes et vous l'avez
dit en particulier avec les cinq
matinées c'est
important un témoignage lorsque nous
sommes allés en audition sur le terrain
dans la banlieue parisienne il nous a
été dit en particulier dans les villes à
quartier difficile que c'est une vraie
chance pour les enfants de maternelle de
quartier difficile d'avoir une matinée
de classe de plus le mercredi matin donc
ça c'est quelque chose auquel tout le
monde enfin reconnaît l'intérêt bien
évident évidemment l'étape organisé
comme à l'école primaire c'est sans
doute pas du niveau et de l'intérêt de
la maternelle mais travailler sur tout
ce qui est la pause méridienne des
moments de calme des moments de repos
euh je je prendrai un exemple là tout à
fait non partisan Alain Jupé que nous
avons rencontré lundi à toute une
réflexion sur la mise en place du TAP à
l'école maternelle avec une formation de
ces personnels d'école maternelle autour
du sommeil de la lecture de compte de
l'écoute musicale qui à mon avis peut
aussi être une bonne pratique à à
reproduire voilà derniers mot dans
les donc dans les retours que nous avons
euh vous le dites bien on va pas avoir
non plus une évaluation et ça serait pas
honnête de de pouvoir se prononcer avec
seulement 6 mois de recul néanmoins
lorsque nous sommes allés dans les
communes de la banlieu bordel aise avec
des communes qui sont en ZEP et en très
grande difficulté il y a quelque chose
qui est mesuré là vraiment au bout de 6
mois c'est une baisse de la violence et
de l'agressivité et je pense que ça et
avec une chute une une une école une
commune a fait une étude une baisse de
70 % des accidents scolaires qui se
passaient entre M et de donc ça c'est un
élément extrêmement important parce ça
participe bien sûr de la ttention et de
la réussite voilà les quelques
question peut-être qu' m'en reviend mais
je pense que j'ai suffisamment parlé
voilà merci madame le rapporteur juste
pour pour ajouter permettez-moi monsieur
le ministre il est en fait des nouvelles
difficultés de nouvelles inquiétudes qui
sont soumises au au maire qui sont liées
au fait que le décret et la circulaire
ne sont pas encore à la disposition des
maires et que les informations qu'ils
peuvent avoir ne sont que des bribes
d'informations qu'ils peuvent recueillir
à travers les médias et en plus de cela
il y a une pression supplémentaire qui
est celle de dire et ça vous allez nous
n nous le confirmer ou non que tout doit
être bouclé pour le 6 juin prochain donc
on a un décret qui n'est pas finalisé ni
une circulaire finalisé et le 6 juin
prochain les maires doivent déposer leur
nouveau dossier ça fait des inquiétudes
supplémentaires et beaucoup
d'interrogations monsie le
ministre alors je vais essayer de
répondre je vais commencer par
cela fais quoi 15 jours que je suis
ministre 3
semaines non mais c'était un dossier qui
était de toute façon pendant et et que
mon prédécesseur aurait traité de la
même manière mais il est incontestable
que la période des élections municipales
qui n'est pas sans expliquer aussi
nombre de difficultés qu'on rencontre
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a une forme de
période blanche où on a le travail a été
mis entre parenthèses quand il a pas
fait l'objet d'une remise en cause
parfois et ça c'est il m'appartient pas
de juger alors là encore c'est la
démocratie est ainsi remett en cause par
les nouvelles équipe ou à tout le moins
quand c'est pas remis en cause le fait
de d'aller creuser voir si on veut bien
si c'est le projet de l'équipe
précédente est bien celui que l'on veut
porter donc on allit une des plusieurs
semaines qui étaient neutralisé sur le
terrain comme incontestablement un
passage de témoins au niveau ministériel
amène à devoir euh pendant au moins une
semaine 15 jours ralentir les les les
choses euh ce que je veux dire c'est que
là on a fait le le le au plus vite voire
même en brutalisant un peu euh no no nos
partenaires pour essayer de partir de ce
que nous avons tous
constaté ce que vous remontez je je
répondrai précisément et compris sur les
conséquences du nouveau décret qui ne se
substitue pas au précédent qui organise
les expérimentations je je veux le dire
ce n'est pas une une invitation à
remettre au travail les 94 % de communes
qui ont ou validé une nouvelle
organisation du temps scolaire ou
travailler dessus rien ninterdit qu'on
retravaille si elle le souhaite mais
c'est pas une substitution à ce qui se
passait c'est une organisation des
expérimentation sur une période de 3 ans
avec une évaluation un suivi qui nous
permettra là avec les les les rectorats
de prendre la mesure de la performance
de ces expérimentations mais nous
complétons ce que j'ai dit dans mon
intervention liminaire nous complétons
un cadre réglementaire qui était fixé
par de nouvelles dispositions qui
permettent d'intégrer des
expérimentations qui ne l'étaient pas
jusqu'ici alors pour être très clair si
une commune qui n'était pas dans les
expérimentations qui avait validé une
organisation du temps scolaire dit bah
écoutez ce projet je l'avais abandonné
avant parce qu'il n'était pas éligible
il le devient je je je le mets en œuvre
c'est tout à fait possible nous aurons
là un temps qui est un temps donc je
concède qu'il n'est
pas long en même temps je vous dirais on
appréciera aussi avec discernement des
situations plus ou moins difficile ce
que je je je je je veux dire c'est que
il est des communes marqué par la
continuité des
équipes qui me donne parfois
l'impression de découvrir le le sujet
maintenant un sujet assez ancien quand
même et je pense que là c'est le dossier
des l'organisation des temps scolaires
et des activités péréscolaires il est
pas arrivé à l'ordre du jour des équipes
municipales il y a 15 jours ce travaill
là il a été effectué la plupart du temps
par les adjoints délégués à ces
questions de vie scolaire d'éducation
depuis longtemps préparé avec les
services imaginz concerté dans le cadre
de la préparation d' d't avec tous les
acteurs locaux qui concourent
aujourd'hui à une mission éducative pour
pour les enfants donc il y a souvent du
travail c'est là où moi il m'appartient
aussi comme ministre de faire preuve de
discernement aentre ce qui relève ce que
je disais d'une difficulté réelle euh ou
d'un combat politique et qui n'est pas
moins respectable que la difficulté
réelle sauf que moi il m'appartient pas
si c'est un combat politique et qui se
manifeste par un désaccord sur le fait
qu'il faille travailler 5 matinées de
suite si c'est un combat politique là
c'est autre chose et c'est sol le du
combat politique classique de la
démocratie qu'il doit avoir lieu mais je
comprends là que mes arguments ne
parviendront pas à convaincre les édiles
de tel ou tel territoire qui sont sur ce
terrainlà mais ce qui m'amène quand même
à leur dire
que la loi la même pour tous que les
décrets quand ils s'appliquent sont les
mêmes pour tous et que ce serait
d'ailleurs un drôle de message éducatif
ou une drôle de pédagogie à l'intention
des citoyens que nous sommes ou à de
tous nos concitoyens que d'expliquer
qu'on peut s'affranchir d'un texte au
motif que la norme serait celle issue
d'un
décret parce que je l'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire matière de par exemple de de
de limitation pour la circul pour la
vitesse matière de circulation c'est
aussi un décretrit dans le code de la
route il viendrait pas à la tête d'un
seul maire de ce pays de dire que 50 kmh
ça doit pas être respecté ou on pourrait
s'en affranchir parce que c'est un
décret c'est
absolument ça semble pas être un
argument tout à fait recevable nous
sommes là dans la préparation une
organisation du temps scolaire qui
relève
d'abord de ma responsabilité celle du
gouvernement et de l'État et nous voyons
d'ailleurs dans vos questions que la
plupart des questions concernent le
périscolaire et là je veux dire deux
choses ce temps ce ces activités
périscolaires sont facultatives pour
l'élève comme pour les Mairies et qu'il
peut parfaitement
être imaginé que ces activités montent
en puissance dans le temps sans que au
jour de la
rentrée tous les maires de France
étaient en capacité de proposer du C
C des activités d'éveil en matière de
danse des activités d'éveil en matière
de théâtre de la philatélie et cetera et
cetera je fais volontiirement large des
activités sportives
donc le mieux est l'ennemi du bien en
tout cas tout le tous les maires
recherchent le mieux mais en même temps
c son de raisonner dans l'abstraction
aussi moi je parle des réalités du
terrain et de celle y compris de ma
propre commune trappe dans les ivelines
qui est pas une commune riche et qui a
expérimenter la réforme avec des
difficultés pour une ville pauvre mais
Don nous mesurons nous aujourd'hui pour
nos enfants les mérites et ça personne
nous l'enlèvera personne ne nous
l'enlèvera les mérites pour nos
enfants parce que l'organisation du
temps scolaire qui est de ma
responsabilité qui est de celle de
l'État c'est ce que nous recherchons
aujourd'hui à travers des formules
nouvelles pour qu'ell soi optimale en
direction des enfants de la République
quand ils mettent les pieds dans une
école et quand ils sont censés y
apprendre ces apprentissages
fondamentaux que nous avons aussi pensé
dans le cadre des programmes qui vont
être revu révisé pour bon nombre d'entre
eux dans le cadre de la refondation de
l'école mais c'est ça notre travail
après je je vais répondre à vos question
une par une est-ce que ce décret se
substitue à l'autre non et et j'ai
est-ce que ma réponse était suffisante
voilà le sentiment d'abandon parce que
les i Azen sont peut-être pas toujours
disponible je crois comprendre que c'est
cela moi j'ai donné des instructions dès
mon arrivée à l'ensemble des recteurs je
mobilise par l'érectorat et les services
de la DGESCO et de mon cabinet les
inspecteurs d'académie les daazen sur le
terrain pour qu'il soit dans cette
période les plus disponibles poss
possible et s'il est des difficultés
signalez-les moi j'essaierai de de de de
faire en sorte qu'elle soit réglé mais
en même temps c'est pas comme ça que
l'essentiel c'est que vous sachiez que
les instructions sont passées et et
si je travaillerai à ce que ce
soit efficient sur le terrain sur le
péri scolaire je vous le dis je rappelle
le caractère
facultatif au
passage certains élus auettent de dire
que quand ils
revendiquent qu'ils n'organiseront que
de la garderie même plus plus ils
percevront 50 € par
enfant ils percevront malgré tout 50 €
par enfant et que la question qui sera
posée à ces élus qui délibérément
n'organisent pas les activités
périscolaires c'est aussi de dire qui
s'agit un peu d'être cohérent ce qui
n'enlève rien aux questions que vous
posez sur
50 + 40 quand on est dans zone rurale
défavorisé ou zone urbaines sensible
plus le cas échiant 54 € quand on
bénéficie de l'argent de la CAF 144 €
par enfant est-ce que c'est toujours
suffisant dans une commune qui avait
déjà une tradition d'accueil
péréscolaire c'est souvent suffisant
dans une commune qui démarre le
péricolaire du vraiment du début ça peut
supposer et ça supposera une
contribution de la collectivité il y a
des collectivités d'ailleurs qui vous
disent nous avons fait le choix depuis
très longtemps d'organiser le
pérécolaire par choix politique de
droite comme de gauche par choix
politique parce que c'est un
investissement que nous considérons
indispensable pour les enfants de nos
communes d'autres qui vous disent ça
n'était pas un investissement ça ne
correspondait pas à nos priorité nous ne
l'avons pas fait là encore la situation
est aussi variée qu'il existe de Mair de
de français donc moi je regarde ces
situation avec un œil aussi intéressé
dans une commune qu'une autre mais je
rappelle que mon travail de ministre de
l'éducation c'est le temps scolaire le
temps scolaire d'abord et ensuite de me
préoccuper des conditions de mise en
œuvre d'une réforme dès lors que elle
suppose et sollicite la coopération et
qu'elle sera optimale cette réforme dès
lors que l'on facilite ou que l'on
favorise l'épanouissement de l'enfant
aussi par le périscolaire mais ma
compétence elle se fonde d'abord sur
l'organisation du temps scolaire vous
avez évoqué l'étape et et toutes les
difficultés qui qui qui existe je
rencontre à 18h ou en tout cas dans la
soirée le directeur général ou la
directrice le directeur général de la
CAF avec lequel je vais évoquer un
certain nombre de ces difficultés euh
qui m'ont été signalé qui pent à la fois
sur le résultat de l'expérimentation sur
des taux d'encadrement allégé pour
l'ensemble du tempérécolaire peut-on
maintenir cela ou pas et quel est
l'impact financier pour les CAF et donc
la CAF cela suppose évidemment qu'il on
puisse interroger les maires sur les
intentions qui sont les en terme
d'organisation du tempsérécolaire et je
je je discute j'ai changé avec le
président de la MF ce matin monsieur
péissard et et un questionnaire
parviendra sera envoyé à tous les maires
sur les prévisions qui sont les leurs le
7 mai de façon à ce qu'on puisse
disposer d'une capacité d'évaluation de
l'impact financier qui sera celui d'une
d'un maintien du de cette
expérimentation sur des taux
d'encadrement à léger au-delà de la
période de juin c'est évidemment un un
un point tout à fait important vous
évoquiez les les gris de qualification
qui sont exigés même si le décret du 2
août prévoyait déjà des des des
allègements en tout cas des des ou des
souplesses possibles sur ces questions
là encore j'ai sollicité ma collègue
Najat valobelkassem qui a tutelle sur la
jebva sur les jeunesses et les sports
pour voir de de quelle façon sur ces
questions sans remettre en cause ce qui
doit être euh la qualification et la
compétence des intervenants sinon les
parents nous le reprocheraient on et la
sécurité qui entoure les activités parce
que si on a des intervenants qui n'ont
aucune notion des sécurités élémentaires
dont ils doivent entourer les activités
périscolaires les maires seront mis en
cause les et vous-même et nous-même
d'avoir autorisé cela mais que l'on voit
comment dans un certain nombre de cas
pour des intervenants qui sont des
intervenants
occasionnels pour un certain nombre
d'activités nous pouvons là encore
aménager ou pas les règles existantes là
encore je suis prudent parce que je vois
bien c'est toujours pareil dans tel cas
particulier on dira c'est quand même inv
vraisemblable que vous ayez refusé la
possibilité pour tel professeur de
musique
tel ancienne
herboriste diplômé remarquable de
pouvoir intervenir au motif qu'elle a
pas le Bafin et cette personne et c'est
vrai que au cas par cas on va trouver ça
absurde mais en même temps si demain on
se retrouve avec des intervenants dont
on nous dit parce que c'est aussi ce
qu'on me dit de la part des parents
d'élèves dans le périscolaire mais avant
même que la réforme des rythmes
scolaires soit existe on trouve des fois
des intervenants on peut se demander si
ils sont toujours capables de pouvoir
encadrer nos enfants et cetera et cetera
donc il faut trouver l'équilibre et
l'équilibre est entre la norme les
règles existantes et la généralisation
de ce dispositif là encore je je vous
dis j'engagerai des discussions de façon
à faire euh euh h à permettre cela je
termine bon la knaf j'ai essayé de
répondre et les
CAF c'est effectivement dans le
cadre d'un accueil loisir sans
hébergement qui est validé comme tel il
y a des règles
euh qui enclenche une dépense pour la
knnaf qui a elle-même aussi un
environnement en terme de dépense
publique qui
est contraint
euh je veux le dire c'est pas on est
quand même dans un contexte qui est un
contexte que vous n'ignorez pas puisque
je crois que sur la plupart des bancs
j'ai bien dit sur la plupart que je ne
me fâche avec personne je a les des
bancs où on ne demande pas de réduire la
dépense publique ça ne m'échappe pas sur
la plupart des bancs on demande la
réduction de la dépense
publique et en même temps on veut que
l'école soit meilleure on veut que les
services publics soient plus efficaces
et on a tous des solutions l'occurrence
ce gouvernement défend et les met sur la
table et je vois bien et soyons honnête
que la concomitance entre le plan de 50
milliards d'euros et la contribution qui
est demandée aux collectivités locales
euh vient à un moment où certains MRES
disent bah écoutez à ce momentl si on
nous demande d'être mis à contribution
la réforme des rythmes scolaires c'est
plus difficil
euh j'entends parce que ces arguments
sont donnés en même
temps j'ai souvenir que dans les
campagnes électorales encore aujourd'hui
dans tous les documents politiquesou
électoraux tout le monde veut à minima
50 milliards voire jusqu'à 130 milliards
d'euros et en même temps tout le monde
veut qu'on ait pour ce qui est de notre
école une école qui
assure des missions les plus efficaces
et les plus performantes le mot
performance prenez-le bon d'ailleurs je
le prends plus performante possible
pour oui c'est non oui là je parle pas
d'école compétitive non mais performante
au sens où les mission de l'école c'est
que en tout cas à la fin du CM2 vous
sachiez lire français parler le français
écrire le français compter correctement
je rappelle que la journée de défense et
de citoyenneté qui a été l'occasion d'un
test grandeur nature sur 750000 jeunes
de 17 ans en 2013 a montré quoi que 10 %
de ces jeunes ne maîtrisaient pas en
français en mathématique les règles
fondamentales mais je vois que ça vous
fait soupirer certains mais moi je suis
ministre de l'éducation nationale et ça
ça n'est pas acceptable et mon travail
c'est de lutter contre cela et je sais
que ce travail ce sera du moyen et long
terme et pour commencer et réussir en
moyen et long TER terme faut réussir la
réforme des rythmes scolaires et donc ce
que je ne négocierai pas c'est l'intérêt
général et l'intérêt général à mes yeux
c'est la réforme des rythmes scolaires
en
2014 merci Monsieur le Ministre les
questions de nos collègues j'ai
plusieurs demandes d'intervention donc
monsieur de leè monsieur gatolin
monsieur housousson Monsieur Le Gendre
madame Michel madame
Gillot voilà on va commencer monsieur le
ministre souhaitez-vous une une série de
question
oui oui tout à la fois ça vous ira
monsieur le ministre allez on y va donc
monsieur
delè merci madame la Présidente avant de
poser un certain nombre de questions
très précises je voudrais
saluer une évolution dans le discours du
ministre de l'éducation
nationale je je veux y déceler une
volonté de trouver des solutions là où
il y a des problèmes plutôt que de dire
qu'il y en a pas et je je veux le le
remercier de ce point de vue quelques
questions très précises monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit le temps scolaire
c'est de ma responsabilité je l'entends
bien j'ai bien compris que les 5
demi-journées les 5 demi les 5 matinées
de la semaine ça c'était pas négociable
on est d'accord
là-dessus ma question très concrètement
qu'est-ce qui est nég l' après-midi
parce que à un moment donné ce que nous
nous pouvons proposer impacte forcément
ne serait-ce qu'en terme d'horaire le
temps que vous revendiquez comme étant
un temps scolaire donc très concrètement
si nous
disons dans ma commune ce qui était le
cas jusque à la semaine dernière on va
peut-être
évoluer c'est 1h30 et pas 3/4 d'heure
est-ce que c'est négocié qu'est-ce qui
décide dans cette affaire très
concrètement et j'ajouteraiis une autre
question vous nous avez dit il y a aussi
une possibilité de jouer sur la
réduction des des
vacances je vois mal mais mais pourquoi
pas que je
puisse décider tout seul sur ma commune
1500 habitants que la scolarité ou la
sortie va se faire le 14 juillet plutôt
que que le le 7 juillet je pense que
quand même il y a un
minimum d'organisation et de
coordination au niveau du département
donc je voudrais savoir moi qui décide
très concrètement de ces dérogations et
j'ajoute je voudrais quelques précisions
par rapport au
décret vous nous avez dit il est pas
abrogé vous nous avez dit il est pas a
écrit mais vous nous avez dit il est
assoupli pour intégrer des
expériences
euh ça veut quand même dire qu'à un
moment donné vous
allez je pense par voie de décret le
compléter d'une façon ou d'une autre
donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit très
précis sur cette affaire làà et la
question qui me vient
derrière cont tenu de la réécriture de
ce décret est-ce que ce que nous avons
pu envoyer
au service académique il y a maintenant
3 mois en ce qui me concerne on peut
revenir dessus c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai
fait une réunion la semaine dernière
très concrètement où les familles et les
enseignants disent bah après
tout pourquoi pas une après-midi entière
de tape alors qu'on avait prévu des des
séquences
d'1h30 3è question je voudrait qu'on
soit très précis sur le statut juridique
d'étape parce que il me semble que il y
a des notions qui chevauchent là-dedans
le TAP par définition vous nous avez dit
la limite vous êtes pas tenu de le faire
c'est pas du temps scolaire c'est du
périscolaire donc c'est municipal bien
moi jusqu'à maintenant j'avais tout
bêtement un centre de loisirs est-ce
qu'on peut assimiler un centre de
loisirs à un tap c'est très concret ça
euh c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu d'avoir un
centre de loisir qui fonctionne tout le
mercredi je peux imaginer un centre de
loisirs qui fonctionne par par de
demi-journée ce qui d'un point de vue
prment financier n'est pas forcément une
mauvaise
idée sur les financements est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire si le fond
d'amorçage et les 50 € que vous avez
évoqué c'est uniquement
2014-25 où est-ce que vous pensez que ce
sera pérenisé et enfin je sais très bien
que ce que je vais vous dire à peu de
chance
euh de susciter chez vous une adhésion
totale et parfaite mais moi j'ai
questionné les maires dans ma dans mon
département être très Fran avec vous il
y a pas d'objection à la
réforme
simplement sur le principe simplement et
vous l'avez souligné dans vos propos il
trouent des situations et avec
l'ouverture que vous faites trouve des
situations qui qui qui les font
souhaiter certainement la réaffirmation
du principe mais mais peut-être la
moratoire d'un an pour qu'on puisse
discuter parce que quand je vois les
délais que vous nous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure et la manière dont ça se passe
chez nous je pense que c'est pareil dans
tous les départements je crains que ce
soit un peu je veux pas employer un gros
mot mais un peu désorganiser au mois de
septembre et je ne suis pas le seul à le
penser
merci merci chers collègues nous avons
une série de de cinq questions encore
cinq intervenants encore je vous
demanderai chers collègues d'être le
plus précis le plus concis possible et
et de poser vos questions de de façon le
plus rapidement possible merci pardon
monsieur gatoula merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre tout
d'abord je voulais vous remercier et
vous féliciter pour votre discours
liminaire parce que vous avez rappelé
une chose c'est que votre priorité c'est
la lutte contre les inégalités au niveau
de l'école et je crois qu'il faut bien
réinscrire l'importance de la réforme
des rythmes scolaires mais aussi sa
nécessité de l'intégrer comme un des
éléments au sein de la refondation de
l'école de la lutte contre les inégalité
et il faut faire attention quand on
parle de réforme des rythmes scolaires
on peut dans certains cas se retrouver
dans des situations et j'évoquerai le
cas postérieurement paradoxal posant
parfois des problèmes ce qui va dans le
sens du rythme scolaire peut aller
parfois dans la difficulté pour certains
élèves l'autre élément aussi pour lequel
je tiens à vous féliciter et vous
remercier c'est vous avez utilisé le
terme d'expérimentation alors en tant
qu'écologiste je suis particulièrement
sensible à cette question mais je crois
que nous sommes tous dans une période de
mutation sensi à ces questions et je
crois que d'ouvrir en fonction des
situations et des villes alors moi je
suis pas élu de de de commune de
montagne je suis élu des haut scène
comme ma consur et collègue et ami
Brigitte contier main nous avons été
saisis effectivement d'un cas assez
particulier qui est celui de la ville de
jeunevillier une ville particulièrement
sensible en terme de population c'est
une ville riche parce qu'elle a des
activités elle a des grandes entreprises
mais elle a une population très pauvre
et c'est vrai que il y a un effort qui
est fait qui est énorme de la part de la
municipalité c'est 3000 € par an pour
les enfants dans la classe d'âge qui
sont qui sont consacrés par la
municipalité donc aujourd'hui des
activités existent mais il faut un
assouplissement vous avez parlé du
problème des équipes mais il y a aussi
celle des équipements et par exemple à
jeun Villier effectivement des séquences
ou des séances 45 minutes voire même
d'unhure ou 1h3 sont insuffisantes si on
veut amener les enfants des quartiers
périphériques dans des équipements de
qualité et Dieu sait si la ville de
jeunevillier en compte avec des des très
très bons équipements au centre et donc
si on veut organiser vous l'avez évoqué
la possibilité de faire des roulements
par demi-journée bien entendu l'après
midi et ne pas toucher à la matinée on
est bien d'accord là-dessus c'est
quelque chose d'essentiel et on a eu
l'occasion avec les services de de votre
prédécesseur d'évoquer cette question là
et la question des délai est quand même
compliquée parce que nous à jeunevillier
il y a eu un dossier qui était déposé
qui n'a pas dans un premier temps été
accepté on est retourné vers le
ministère pour obtenir une dérogation
aujourd'hui nous fin avril il ou début
mai il faut avoir posé les choses et et
les moyens sont mis et la volonté
politique et je dis attention il est
important aussi que ces demi-journées
dans les villes sensibles comme celle-ci
elle soit à horaire de fermeture d'école
à peu près équivalente parce que qui dit
tape non obligatoire en faisant la
gratuité comme c'est le cas dans une
ville comme jeune Villier c'est une
manière de ne pas laisser les enfants à
la dérive parce que on a eu des retraits
d'école on a un jeu communautariste
extrêmement fort il y a une liste
municipale à jeunevillier qui avait
quand même trois élus sur un discours
comm unotariste très très dur on a 400
enfants qui ont fait l'objet de retrait
de l'école ces derniers mois donc il
faut être aussi là si on veut prendre
l'ensemble des inégalités il faut que la
continuité entre guillemets temporaire
entre le temps scolaire et le temps
périscolaire soit bien intégré que les
parents puissent à 4h ou à 4h30 tous les
jours venir enfin à l'exception du
mercredi venir chercher les enfants
parce que si on est sur des horaires
irréguliers dans un sentiment de
facultatif et bien il y a déjà des
contre organisations du temps
périscolaire par des organismes
religieuxs bien merci monsieur gatolin
je rappelle encore une fois qu'il faut
être beaucoup plus court et plus pr
monsieur le ministre a des impératifs et
on souhaiterait quand même entendre ses
réponses euh monsieur
Husson merci Monsieur le Ministre
rapidement donc déjà
pour vous dire que ce ce dossier on va
l'appeler comme ça il est pas évident à
prendre puisque que si je ne me trompe
pas il fait suite à une lettre du
Premier ministre du précédent d'ailleurs
monsieur hér trois décrets trois
circulaire un arrêé je me félicite
simplement qu'on nit pas décidé enfin
que votre gouvernement n'est pas décidé
par ordonnance parce que ça aurait été
une véritable catastrophe vous vous
apercevez que ce que je dis ne peut pas
être d'ailleurs teinté d'esprit partisan
c'est simplement le pragmatisme
d'ailleurs que je veux souligner au
travers de votre présence que j'apprécie
et par rapport à un projet qui a été
décidé là aussi par votre
prédécesseur m'inquiéter comme ça a été
dit notamment par Dominique mais
également par Madame la rapporteur et
madame la Présidente du
délai que je vais appeler très court
entre le prochain décret et la prochaine
circulaire avant le 6 juin très
honnêtement pour moi aussi avoir
interrogé les 594 communes de mon
département au mois de janvier et à peu
près 150 communes ont répondu ce qui euh
ce qui ou syndicats intercommunaux ce
qui permet de dire que un tiers des
communes ont répondu au questionnaire
qui est le questionnaire de la mission
sénatoriale parce que je pense qu'il
faut respecter le travail sénatorial
d'aucun on pensé que c'était une que
j'étais partisan j'ai simplement repris
en le précisant et en le précisant
d'ailleurs je veux le souligner parce
que dans les difficultés on n
malheureusement pas pu rencontrer dans
dans la visite qui a été organisée en
mtemiselle une difficulté particulière
en Milie rural sur les regroupements
pédagogiques intercommunaux multicit
vous prenez un exemple je l'ai je vais
vous dire comment organiser alors vous
avez légèrement assoupli c'est bien
c'est un pas mais quand vous avez se se
villages avec encore trois communes qui
accueillent une école et puis une 4ème
qui accueille une cantine parce qu'à un
moment ils ont accepté de d'abandonner
l'école et ils ont il ils ont plus
accueillir la cantine parce que tout ça
ça coûte moins cher reconnaissez
qu'aujourd'hui quand les dotations
baissent et qu'on vous demande de
d'essayer de faire l'artiste et que dans
le même temps le comment dirais-je le
transport méridien n'est plus pris en
charge comme par le passé et c'est en
train de se mettre en œuvre par une
collectivité ça c'est l'affaire des uns
et des autres en l'occurrence c'est
notre département le Conseil général
mais il faut bien comprendre et je pense
que vous le comprenez bien que c'était
extrêmement difficile trisème point
important je vous ai saisi comme le
premier ministre euh hier donc mais je
l'ai fait hier parce que j'attendais
d'avoir nous avons visité une commune
qui a 20 ans de pratique 20 ans de
pratique c'était l'aménagement du temps
de l'enfant avec alors au départ il y
avait le concours de la CAF il y avait
le concours du conseiller général de
meurtemosel tous ces braves gens se sont
évaporés dans la nature c'est à Laxou le
maire nous a adressé enfin adressé son
projet éducatif territorial modifiieré
il est pour les rythmes scolaires il
vous explique alors il a tout hein il a
l'aménagement de l'enfant il a Miss
réussite éducative il a il est également
en zone d'éducation prioritaire les les
choix sont faits école par école dans sa
commune il vous alerte et il vous
demande soit de sursoir sur les cinq
matinées pour les écoles maternelles
c'est parfaitementé expliqué nous
appuyons également la demande parce
qu'il vous dit en même temps il vous
donne tous les chiffres les coûts les
difficultés j'ai entendu les familles
qui à un moment ont des enfants en même
temps en maternelle et en élémentaire
mais d'abord c'est pas le cas toutes les
familles puis ça finit par s'arrêter un
jour mais surtout les mêmes familles
c'est à la demande des famille il y a
une réunion tout a été l'évaluation a
été faite et puisque je parle
d'évaluation permettez-moi de vous dire
comme ça vous verrez que c'est là aussi
c'est je dirais toute sensibilité tout
gouvernement confondu et donc toute
académie confondu 20 ans de pratique
jamais aucune évaluation n'a été faite
par personne sur les dispositifs jamais
aucune évaluation n'a été faite donc si
en même temps vous pouvez pour cette
commune notamment avec 20 ans de
pratique je crois qu' a un moment c'est
quand même quelques centaines de
milliers d'euros c'est un choix que la
commune a fait et aujourd'hui elle nous
dit ça a été dit devant nos collègues
elle dit moi je garde la même enveloppe
j'ai moins de dotation je veux faire
autant si ça n'est pas possible et bien
je serais obligé de reconsidérer l'offre
qui est validée par la communauté
éducative les parents et qui donne
satisfaction à tout le monde les efforts
vous l'avez dit on dé limite j'ai même
lu il y a peu de temps vous disiez tout
ça enfin c'est cet argent supplémentaire
que vous nous demandez ça ne se trouve
pas sous le sabot d'un cheval c'était je
crois vous avez dit de l'ordre de 400
millions mais le cheval hier il a bien
heureusement d'ailleurs he pour le pacte
de stabilité on a bien trouvé enfin
éviter de dépenser 500 millions de plus
voilà dernier élément pour dire que
c'est en fait là-dessus que les communes
et les syndicats scolaires sont les plus
attentifs quelle garantie dans le temps
pour ces l'État va pouvoir-t-il va-t-il
pouvoir donner au côté au côté des
collectivités locales qui ne sous-estime
pas l'intérêt de la chose parce que vous
l'avez dit moi j'été de ceux qui ont
aussi voté le dispositif des contrats
d'avenir je crois que la réussite de
ceux qui ou de celles qui ont un moment
des difficultés lorsqu'ils sont jeunes
elles concernent tout le monde donc oui
pour le Paris de la réussite mais
également tout ça ça a un cût et les
cooups doivent être partagés
durablement merci monsieuron en effet
monsieur le ministre nous vous invité
avec madame le rapporteur à prendre
toute la mesure de ce qui est mis en
œuvre à l'xou depuis 20 ans eux ils
mettent 2 heures de T par jour depuis
une vingtaine d'années mais il y a cette
difficulté de la maternelle et du CP
mais je crois que il serait bon monsieur
le ministre que vous vous penchiez sur
cette sur cette expérimentation de 20
ans ensuite Monsieur Le
Gendre merci m la présidente madame la
présidente monsieur le
ministre je suis heureux moi aussi de
voir que vous venez vous venez très vite
après votre prise de fonction rencontrer
notre mission d'information nous avions
souhaité recevoir votre prédécesseur et
finalement ça n'avait pas pu se faire ce
qui est soute regrettable mais on me
permettra de euh dire que j'aurais été
encore plus satisfait si vous aviez pu
peut-être venir rencontrer notre mission
d'information avant de faire vos
premières annonce nous avions travaillé
pendant des semaines nous étions un
ensemble de sénateurs
préoccupé de cette question et c'est
pourquoi nous avions les uns et les
autres voulu cette mission d'information
je pense qu'il aurait été encore pour
les parlementaires plus satisfaisant que
d'être entendu par vous avant de faire
vos premières annonces ceci dit je crois
aussi qu'il est nécessaire de d'apporter
maintenant des clarifications car vos
annonces n'ont pas contribué totalement
à clarifier le débat monsieur le
ministre je vois dans le journal de ma
région la voix du du Nord pour ne pas la
nommer une déclaration très inquiète
d'une grande chronobiologiste qu'on
connaît ici claire lecte qui explique je
suis stupéfaite par cette annonce votre
annonce cela fait 17 ans à Lille plus
longtemps dans d'autres villes que les
matinées de travail était de 4h car
c'est le moment où les enfants sont les
plus concentrés je ne comprends pas
pourquoi ce ne sera plus possible les
enseignants vont devoir revoir leurs
copies alors que leur projet éducatif
fonctionne depuis des années anné donc
vous voyez qu'il y a des inquiétudes sur
ce point-là également et puis je vois
les questions qui me sont posés
spontanément par des maires moi aussi
j'avais envoyé le questionnaire de notre
mission d'information à tous les maires
du département et j'ai reçu de très
nombreuses réponses qui montraient leur
préoccupation et là j'ai reçu encore
aujourd'hui en leur disant que j'allais
vous rencontrer quelques souhait de
questions la première qui revient ça
elle porte sur votre volonté de réformer
les rythmes scolaires dans le cadre de
l'annualité c'est bien de revoir la
semaine mais il y avait un problème de
réforme nécessaire des rythmes scolaires
sur l'année monsieur le ministre la
question qui m'est posé par les
enseignants d'une commune qui s'appelle
Esther dans le Nord une petite ville ù
dans lequel on est mobilisé là aussi
pour le rythme scolaire c'est pas des
adversaires c'est des gens qui posent
des questions est-ce qu'il y a une
réelle volonté d'engager une ré flexion
autour de ce projet de réforme du
calendrier annuel et de la faire aboutir
deuxème question elle est récurrente
quelle garantie l'état assure-t-il au
collectivités locales pour péreniser
l'aide si le fond d'amorçage reconduit
pour 2014-2015 se tarit j'entends bien
que vous avez appelé vous rappelé tout à
l'heure que nous devons tous lutter
contre les dépenses mais là vous nous
incitez à des dépenses supplémentaires
et comme les cè acité local ne peuvent
pas utiliser deux fois l'effort qu'elles
vont pouvoir faire pour l'éducation si
nous le faisons pour les rythmes
scolaires nous ne l'aurons pas pour
d'autres aides apporté aux écoles qui
peuvent également permettre aux enfants
de réussir mieux alors nous
souhaiterions que l'on puisse avoir des
éléments d'évaluation pour savoir si
c'est la réforme des rythmes scolaires
ou si c'est la modernisation des
équipements des écoles et cetera qui
permettront à nos élèves de de réussir
mieux et donc nous aider à faire les
bons choix et je crois que c'est une
demande légitime de la part des uns et
des autres et positive une autre
question aussi je pense qu'elle est pas
inintéressante la multiplicité des
adultes qui auront les enfants en charge
et les conséquences de l'univers
éducatif ont-elles toutes été évoqué ou
évalué personnel de garderie de
restaurations scolaires qui s'ajoutent
déjà aux enseignants aux intervenants
scolaires le morcellement du temps de
l'enfant et la perte de ses repères
risque d'être des facteurs négatifs dans
son développement et ses acquisitions
voilà une question qui m'est posée pour
lequel j'aimerais avoir également votre
sentiment merci Monsieur Le Gendre
monsieur le ministre pour une
information complète notre mission
commune d'information avait décidé
d'élaborer un questionnaire assez simple
qui a été transmis à l'ensemble des des
sénateurs et nous avons quand même 60
questionnaires qui nous ont été euh qui
qui nous sont parvenus nous nous en
avons fait une synthèse qui va être donc
publiée dans notre
rapport madame Michel
oui moi je viens d'un département
où enfin l'application c'est de des
rythmes scolaires de cette modification
c'est s'est faite à plus de 70 % dès
2013 euh ça ça a posé des problèmes de
mise en place comme partout mais
considéré comme une expérimentation pas
plus qu'ailleurs il av une volonté de
d'appliquer cette réforme elle
s'applique bien ma question ne pose ne
ne concerne pas les Landes mais euh ma
lecture avec Madame la rapporteur juste
avant cette réunion nous avons lu La
Marseillaise et nous avons vu que
Jean-Claude Gudin dans le conseil à
l'issue du conseil municipal hier a a
conclu en disant qu'il n'appliqueraiit
pas les rythmes tant que il ne serait
pas euh euh payé par l'État donc moi ma
question c'est comment faire enfin
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut
envisager pour éviter que cette décision
ce refus d'application ne fasse
école merci beaucoup madame Michel
madame Gillot
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre moi j'ai bien noté que vous
maintenez l'affirmation des cinq
matinées d'apprentissage comme fondement
d'une meilleure réussite d'apprentissage
des élèves c'est un objectif qui est
poursuivi par la loi de refondation de
l'école et je rappelle à à nos collègues
que c'est pas simplement un décret hein
c'est une loi qui a été discutée amendée
adoptée par le Parlement hein cette
cette loi qui est une des lois
fondamentales maintenant de de notre
République donc alors il y a eu
plusieurs questions sur la la la la
compréhension de votre de votre
assouplissement donc j'y reviendrai pas
simplement je je voudrais vous demander
que pensez pensez-vous que donner la
possibilité de regrouper les activités
périscolaires en une seule en en une
seule demi-journée donc un après-midi
respecte le principe de la refondation
d'école qui visait l'All l'allègement de
la journée de classe des enfants en
permettant la découverte éventuelle
d'activités culturelles sportive
éducative ludique propice à l'éveil des
enfants dans un temps de l'enfant qui se
trouve à l'école et je rejoins les
constats et les propositions de mon mon
collègue gatholin je pense que la
meilleure la meilleure solution la
meilleure organisation c'est de
maintenir un horaire d'accueil des
enfants de 27h avec 24 he d'enseignement
et puis 3 He
d'activité alors plus ou moins
qualitative en fonction de la de la
formation des des agents de la formation
des intervenants mais avec une une
harmonisation de la prise en charge des
enfants et une confiance établie dans
cette prise en charge parce que moi je
voudrais quand même rappeler que il y a
il y a quelques temps les parents se
satisfaisaient étaient très heureux que
leurs enfants découvre un après-midi
l'activité à la ferme d'à côté chez le
boulanger voilà et à ce momentlà
personne ne se posait la question de
savoir si le boulanger la fermière avait
le BAFA avait les compéten enfin tout ça
bon les enfants étaient sous la
responsabilité de leur enseignants mais
dans les activités p scolaire ils sont
sous la responsabilité d'un responsable
de l'éducation euh communale qui a toute
compétence pour assumer cette
responsabilité sous l'autorité du maire
donc je vois bien que aujourd'hui euh
les les les maires sont très très
anxieux à l'idée d'avoir une
responsabilité particulière dans
l'organisation de ces temps nouveaux
mais euh quand on organise des centres
de loisir quand on organise des des
camps de vacances on a déjà cette
responsabilité làà et je pense pense
qu'il faut pas complexifier au maximum
un cadre qui mérite d'être souple dans
l'intérêt des enfants et de faire en
sorte que l'école soit le lieu
bienveillant d'accueil des enfants
pendant un temps ou un moment ils sont
sous la responsabilité de l'éducation
nationale un moment sont sous la
responsabilité du maire et il y a des
des des des lieux de discussion et de de
de de cohérence de ces partenariats qui
font que la responsabilité peut être
peut être euh préciser euh ensuite vous
parlez d'alléger la semaine en réduisant
le nombre d'heures d'école euh par
semaine en étalant ses heures sur les
vacances ne craignez-vous pas de créer
de la confusion dans la cohérence des
des emplois des des des emplois du temps
des calendriers des temps de vie
professionnel familial déjà difficile à
faire concorder s'il s'agit d'une petite
commune et d'une à l'intérieur d'une
organisation départementale qui ne Pr
prévoit pas ce type de de de de
dérogation pardonnez-moi madame Gillot
j'ai encore madame labord qui
souhaiterait intervenir je suis désolée
madame Trel mais chaque fois que je
prends la parole dans cette mission
c'est toujours à la fin que vous me la
donnez à chaque fois vous me dites que
je suis trop vous n'êtes pas la dernière
madame vous n'êtes pas la derni j'en
j'ai encore deux questions j'ai encore
deux questions euh je voudrais aussi
rappeler que le CNFPT s'est organiser
pour offrir des formations
conventionnelles aux collectivités
locales pour améliorer élever le niveau
de qualification des personnels
communaux qui seront amenés à prendre en
charge les activités éducatives
complémentaires l'étape mais là aussi
attention de ne pas trop complexifier
les cadres qui qui quel parce que sinon
on a plus de possibilité d'agir et on
est paralysé par la peur de de de la
légalité et puis sur l'efficience sur le
terrain des des des inspecteurs de de de
l'Académie et des dazenes pour
accompagner les collectivités bon moi je
pense qu'il y en a qui sont tout à fait
prêts simplement ils ont aussi une
paralysie par rapport à l'organisation
des temps d'enseignement de leurs élèves
moi je me suis fait répondre que c'était
très compliqué d'organiser les temps
partiels et les temps pleins les les
remplacements l'accueil des stagiaires
les formations quand les les les les
emplois du
temps n'était pas cohérent d'une commune
à une autre donc ça c'est une difficulté
que l' administration de que votre
administration doit dépasser pour
pouvoir répondre justement à cette
conjugaison des temps de l'enfant pris
en charge à la fois par l'Éducation
nationale à la fois par les
collectivités locales dans l'intérêt des
enfants et pas simplement dans l'intérêt
des
adultes merci beaucoup madame Gillou
madame
Laborde merci je vous promets que je
vais être très très courte euh parce que
justement il faut avir le temps de la
réponse mais je vais rebondir sur la
dernière remarque de ma collègue parce
que je pense d'abord monsieur le
ministre vous remarquez que c'est
toujours aussi passionné quand on parle
d'éducation nationale et que notre
mission va se terminer mais elle
pourrait durer encore une année
peut-être qu'on demandera une
prolongation euh parce que excellente
idée voilà parce que vu que c'est
évolutif il faut que nous puissions
continuer à travailler donc juste sur
l'éducation nationale parce que c'est
bien là le souci c'est qu'on a une loi
qui se qui s'appelle refondation et on a
des rythmes scolaires et c'est l'éternel
problème et donc toute cette passion où
nous nous sommes sénateurs et nous
parlons pour l'intérêt général mais bien
sûr nous sommes aussi partiese prenant
sur certaines communes et nous sommes
aussi intérêt particulier et en plus on
peut être papa de deux petits
enfants donc c'est vrai que chacun moi
je suis grand-mère mais je la fais pas
aujourd'hui puisque vous avez fait papa
je fais pas mamie mais c'est pour bien
vous montrer que l'intérêt général et
l'intérêt particulier dans l'éducation
des enfants se trouve très mélangé donc
juste pour rebondir sur ce qu'a dit
Dominique Gillot c'est en effet
l'organisation parce que plus on va
donner de liberté au rythme scolaire
plus on aura de difficultés à gérer le
rythme donc vous éducation nationale
avec les temps partiels est-ce que un
enseignant qui fait par exemple quatre
décharges de Directeur va arriver à
gérer son temps puisque il tombera pas
sur le temps exact euh voilà et je
voulais bien sûr rebondir sur mon
collègue puisqu'il me l'a enlevé de la B
je suis si vous ne le saviez pas encore
madame
laïcité très à fond et c'est sûr que si
on laisse trop de liberté et que tout
est facultatif les enfants de j'allais
dire allez de de famille aisé peuvent
très bien aller faire autre chose et
aller au conservatoire ou ailleurs les
enfants de famille moins aisé
profiteront si leur commune est aisée
parce que de de choses et et peut-être
qu'on a aussi un certain communautaire
qui pourra s'installer parallèlement
voilà mais je vais donc pas rebondir sur
toutes les questions mais je pense que
bon courage merci madame laabord
monsieur le ministre deux questions
sèches que je souhaiterais vous poser
sans Avant
Propos sèche dans le sens pas d'avant
propos les pressions sur les mares pour
renégocier l'organisation et concentrer
l'étape sur le vendredi après-midi vous
vous en doutez bien vont être très très
fortes on on parle de du rythme des des
enfants si d'aventure comme beaucoup de
mères on on l'ont exprimé c'est le
mercredi matin qui sera choisi pour la
demi-journée supplémentaire on peut se
retrouver avec des enfants qui n'ont
plus cours et qui sont à partir du
vendredi midi vendredi midi samedi
dimanche alors que tous les
chronobiologiste semble dire que ça
serait mieux le samedi matin donc il y a
effectivement un risque que les enfants
pendant 2 jours et demi ne sont plus
dans la cellule scolaire et se retrouve
le lundi matin 2è question que se
passe-t-il à l'issue des 3 ans
d'expérimentation les maires seront-ils
contraints de revenir au régime commun
du décret de Monsieur payon ou et sur
quel critère monsieur le ministre euh
allez-vous tenir compte des euh sur quel
critère et en tenant compte de quellees
contraintte allez-vous procéder à
l'évaluation des organisations
expérimental que vous apprêtez à
autoriser voilà c'était un peu merci
monsieur le ministre à
vous alors bon j'ai vous énormément de
questions je vais essayer de le faire
euh avec quelques petites fiches là M
mot bon d'abord dans l'ordre monsieur le
sénateur de lèche qui va que poser
plusieurs questions extrêmement
précises plus généralement je vous
remercier sur la la qualité du de
l'échange que que nous avons parce qu'il
est il est il est constructif et aussi
constructif que ce que j'ai qui ce qui
me revient de de de de partout
c'està-dire que on voit bien qu'il y a
pas qui a consensus sur le diagnostic et
qu'on recherche
ensemble des
solutions assci près
que il y a une variété de communes
autour de nous que les expériences sont
pas les mêmes que les tailles sont pas
les mêmes que les moyens sont pas les
mêmes et que on a une d'abord une
organisation du temps scolaire nouvelle
qui est proposée et quelque chose de
nouveau une invitation à tous les élus à
faire des propositions euh dans une
démarche qui est une démarche très
responsabilisante pour les uns et les
autres euh de faire des propositions
pour une organisation du temps scolaire
ensuite discuté validé par lesadazen par
l'éctorat mais c'est un dialogue qui est
un dialogue Nouveau c'est pour ça que je
voudrais dire que euh euh je trouve
qu'on soit permis de dire qu'on fait
mauvais procès à mon prédécesseur
Vincent payon de de de de pas avoir
suffisamment discuté lui qui est alor
origine de ce dialogue là et et qui fait
qu'il a lieu partout à travers les
intermédiaires qui sont pour nous ceux
des les recteurs les les inspecteurs
d'académie les daenes ce dialogue qui me
semble fécond je veux dire dans les les
questions qui m'ont été posées euh par
vous monsieur le sénateur notamment
celle sur les vacances sur le fait qu'on
allège le temps hebdomadaire admettons
qu'il passe à 23h ce qui veut donc dire
qu'on la dégage 36 he pour 36 semaines
et qui faille reporter ça sur là le le
temps des vacances le choix devant être
fait d'ailleurs à ce momentl l'-il
imputé sur le temps des vacances que
d'été ou est-il sur un autre temps de
vacances h objectivement aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il faut respecter des rythmes
entre les coupures qui sont celles
euh que qui ont lieu tout au long de
l'année en dehors des vacances d'été et
et le temps de ces coupures qui doit
être suffisamment long 15 jours pour
qu'il puisse permettre une vraie
récupération des enfants parce que s'il
est trop rétréci ce temps des vacances
d'hiver de Noël il a et de printemps et
de tout sain il il a aussi un impact sur
les capacités d'apprentissage des
enfants donc on pense assez
naturellement au vacances d'été j'ai vu
que alors je ve les rassurer en même
temps
euh la réaction extrêmement rapide des
professionnels du tourisme qui voyz là
une remise en cause de leurs activités
je je propose d'ailleurs si je peux être
entendu qu'on s'épargne les discours
apocalyptiques sur une semaine de
vacances en moins dans trois communes
d'un département d'une région ne vont
pas entraîner des coortes de
licenciement euh dans les campings les
hôtels les restaurants et toutes les
activités de loisirs donc moi je
respecte toutes les professions euh mais
qu'on s vite ce type de de message tout
à fait inutile dans une période où on a
besoin je je crois et c'est l'état
d'esprit qui est ici euh que face à des
problèmes que l'on analyse ensemble dont
on fait le même diagnostic qu'on se dise
comment on peut essayer de trouver des
solutions puisque c'est exactement comme
ça je crois que vous avez commencé votre
intervention en disant on cherche si en
tout cas on veut trouver des solutions
donc dans ce cas-là quand il y aura une
proposition de de de de cette nature là
si c'est moins de 24 heures elles seront
évidemment dans le cadre d'une
proposition conjointe de plusieurs
communes font l'objet évidemment d'une
d'une sisine du Conseil Général pour
consultation d'une décision à la fin de
de de de l'inspection de l'inspecteur du
recteur d'ailleurs en bout de course
comme de la même manière quand c'est sur
une seule commune quand on propose des
vacances plus courtes il y aura décision
sur la base de la proposition du maire
c'est déjà le cas je veux vous dire j'ai
j'ai déjà des propositions sur la table
qui me viennent je peux pas donner le
nom de commune je ne veux pas gêner les
maires eugard au fait qu'ils m'ont fait
des propositions et que ça les gênerait
que que que ça se sache aujourd'hui mais
j'ai déjà des propositions de villees
importantes qui n'étaient pas passer
encore au nouveau rythme qui intègre
cette proposition là qui sera là examiné
évalué par par les recteurs et dans la
plupart des CS je je lis je pense
autorisé dès lors qu'elle s'entour de
toutes les les les les les les les les
précautions les soins nécessaires à
l'intérêt de l'enfant ce qui me réjouit
je vais vous dire d'ailleurs quel que
soit soit les les les les
chronobiologistes qui parlent et ou les
psychologues en l'occurrence qui parlent
sur le sujet des ryth c'est qu'il est
accord sur les C matinées et et et plus
personne n'en déroge de ces CIN matinées
et j'ai d'illeur dit une bêtise tout à
l'heure j'père que vous me pardonnerez
le texte prévoit que ce ne soit pas
forcément 5 matinées successives si
c'est le samedi matin cela peut être
aussi le samedi matin ce qui permet
d'ailleurs pour répondre par
anticipation une question qui m'était
posée euh par vous-même sur le fait
qu'on libère une après-midi que ça
puisse être le vendredi après-midi
l'optimum en terme de rythme c'est
effectivement de respecter non seulement
le matin comme avec des heures de levée
qui soient identiques mais aussi
d'éviter que les temps de rupture dans
la semaine ne soient pas trop longs
parce qu'en clair
euh pour faire simple l'expression est
pas très jolie mais mais lundi matin on
redémarre la classe quoi et au sens on
la redémarre c'est qu'on redémarre tout
le monde le professeur est compris sans
doute qu'il doit redémarrer se remettre
dans le rythme de sa classe et plus la
rupture a été longue plus le temps pour
redémarrer peut apparaître parfois long
et en tout cas plus la désynchronisation
peut nuire à la qualité des la
concentration nécessaire pour apprendre
donc effectivement l'optimum il pourrait
être là j'observe aujourd'hui qu'il y a
que nous recherchons la réalisation
d'une réforme qui est dans l'intérêt de
l'enfant dès lors qu'il y a 5q matinées
que nous essayons de la rendre
compatible avec euh les réalités de
terrain sur les demandes des élus les
demandes des professeurs les demandes
des parents d'élèves les besoins qui
sont ceux des enfants je pense à la
montagne par exemple la montagne nous
avons là des spécificités dans
l'organisation du calendrier scolaire
est lié au temps nécessaire et a des
mercredis qui peuvent être libérés
quelqu fois dans l'année pour faire du
ski qui suppose là d'organiser le temps
différemment donc on a là des questions
bah c'est le travail de tous les élus
que vous êtes de une fois les principe
de la réforme posée ou de vos choix
confrontés au terrain c'est la manière
dont on aménage ces principes dès lors
que ces principes ne sont pas remis en
cause la méthode qui est associée à la
réussite de la réforme nous sommes là
dans cette phase de mise en œuvre de la
réforme et il est clair que les parents
d'élèves ce sont pas des concepts les
professeurs ce ne sont pas que des
concepts les enfants non plus et les
élus non plus donc comme il ne
m'appartient pas de manipuler seulement
des concepts mais de discuter avec des
êtres de chair et de sang qui ont des
convictions ou des revendications des
demandes des mécontentements des
aspirations des espoirs et des
enthousiasmes bah on doit
euh arbitrer entre tout cela et c'est ce
que nous avons recherché l'intérêt
général à travers les 5 matinées donc
que ce soit en continu le mercredi matin
ou le samedi matin et ensuite une
organisation du du du temps scolaire qui
qui en règle générale c'était le décret
payon on va l'appeler comme ça prévoit
neu demi-journée avec ce complément qui
vient proposer de nouvelles
expérimentations permettra de dégager
euh une après-midi qui pourrait être le
vendredi après-midi et si vous voulez la
conviction du ministre de l'Éducation ou
ce qui pourrait être sa préférence je ne
souhaite pas moi ma préférence mon vœu
ne va pas à ce que ce soit
principalement le vendredi après-midi
que l'on dégage le temps périscolaire je
vois bien euh en quoi ça peut faciliter
euh le déblocage de certaines situations
mais ça n'est pas ma préférence
personnelle sur les chronobiologistes
qu'on parle il y en a qui sont plus
cités que d'autres bon en même temps
notre travail se fonde sur les travaux
de l'Académie de médecine de l'Académie
de pharmacie et de quelques somités qui
euh préconise ce qui a été pensé dans le
cadre du premier décret ce qui le
complète aujourd'hui je ne doute pas
que comme dans toutes les familles il y
a
des sensibilités hein euh
ou des chapelles des sous-chapelles et
qu'il y en a toujours une pour être plus
contente ou plus mécontente que d'autres
de de ce que nous faisons je pense que
en tout cas nous nous sommes là sur un
point d'équilibre qui est un point
d'équilibre important sur l'étape et euh
euh la question qui m'a été posée est-ce
que mon centre de loisir est finalement
d'illeors que c'est un service public
facultatif c'est effectivement il est
juridiquement vous m'avez posé une
question que la réponse est oui c'est
dans ce cadre on peut parfaitement
organiser des activités périscolaires
sur une après-midi qui serait libéré la
question que vous me posiez aussi
c'était puis-je revenir sur
l'organisation de mon là encore je vais
vous dire mon vœux mais après je vais
vous dire le droit mon vœu ce serait que
évidemment parce que ça ne va pas se
passer ainsi heureusement mais qu' on
reprennent pas toutes les copies parce
que tout le temps qu'on prendra qu'on
prendra à refaire les copies on le
prendra pas à aider toutes celles et
ceux qui n'ont pas encore valider pour
des bonnes raisons leur organisation du
temps scolaire à le faire et alors vous
allez me dire mais monsieur Amon faites
donc un moratoire mais je vais pourquoi
je vous répondrai non à ce moratoire
parce que je suis sûr d'une chose c'est
qu'élas les problèmes d'auourd'
auourd'hi seront les mêmes demain et
qu'on me dira au nom du fait que ces
problèmes ont persisté qu'il me faut un
moratoire encore pour l'année d'après je
pense que cette question du moratoire je
l'ai
entendu je ne crois pas que ce soit la
bonne réponse aujourd'hui au problème
tels qu'ils sont posés et je rajoute
puisque là encore la question m'a été
posée par vous madame la sénatrice que
se passe-t-il si un mare décide bah non
je n'ouvre
pas d'abord je le dis ce ne serait pas
très
responsable et puis cette
décision d'organiser le temps scolaire
elle relève de l'état d'une disposition
qui est dans le préambule de la
constitution de 46 qui veut que
l'éducation c'est l'état et que toutes
les dispositions y compris légales
relèvent de
l'État et qu'il décidit de ne pas ouvrir
une école le mercredi matin parce qu'on
n pas
d'accord ou le samedi matin je je je
trouve que honnêtement ce serait une
forme de d'impasse dans laquelle je je
suis certain par contre qu'on ne
trouvera que très très peu d'élus et de
Mair si cette situation devait exister
je vais même ma conviction c'est qu'il
n'y en aura pas pourquoi parce qu'on
travaille à ce qu' n'y en est pas et à
répondre au problèmes quand ils existent
donc un vœ d'un conseil municipal je le
respecte c'est une invitation pour moi à
discuter et à trouver des solutions pas
euh faire un communiqué pour dire c'est
scandaleux que tel conseil municipal est
fait tel veu disant que euh donc voilà
moi je prends ces vuxlà pour une
invitation alors ce qui n'est pas non
plus un encouragement à ce qu'il y ait
des vux dans tous les conseils
municipaux pour dire qu'on va pas faire
la réforme des rythmes que ce soit clair
mais je je prends je prends les les je
je non mais c'est pas ça c'est que je
veux être très honnête je je je regarde
les situations telles qu'elles sont et
j'ai j'ai appelé moi-même Jean-Claude
godudin avant ce vœu nous avons convenu
que nous travaillerons et donc on va
travailler et je lui dis que le recteur
de l'Académie de Marseille monsieur Ali
SAB est à son entière disposition pour
travailler avec lui à lever les
difficultés qu'il peut y avoir sur
cette ville ça m'invite à vous répondre
à la à vous répondre en tout cas à
apporter une
réponse c'est une réponse en même temps
à la question le fond va-t-il être
prolongé ou pas parce que c'est c'est
aussi une demande du maire de de de
Marseille comme d'autres
maires le fond a déjà été il y avait
plusieurs hypothèses la première c'était
de ne faire un fond d'amorçage que de
manière incitative la première année
pour encourager tout le monde à s'y
mettre en 2013 et dire 2014 alors là on
accompagne plus faudra juste se
contenter de ce qu'on peut faire du côté
de la
CAF où là les financements sont pérenes
puisqu'il finan du du du péri scolaire
mais nous avons fait le choix au
contraire choix politique de dire le
fond sera pour l'année de généralisation
et c'est un arbitrage obtenu par Vincent
payon qui était un arbitrage qui ne
coulait pas de source eu égard
effectivement au contexte budgétaire
mais je m'em presse de dire qu'il est
quand même logique dès lors que la
priorité de ce gouvernement réaffirmer
par le Président de la République c'est
la jeunesse et l'école et la refondation
de l'école de la République la question
qui est posée par plusieurs élus c'est
peut-on prolonger ce fond et là il
existe plusieurs scénaris qui seront
appréciés mais qui m'appartient pas de
de trancher aujourd'hui une extinction
sifflé pas de reconduction parce que les
moyens sont aujourd'hui
euh très contraints euh une reconduction
intégrale qui me paraît aujourd'hui
compliquée euh à mettre en œuvre et à
programmer en tout cas cette demande
elle est portée par l' MF la MF en parle
ils me l'ont formulé euh je je je crois
aujourd'hui surtout que nous avons déjà
pris un engagement pour cette année euh
qui est un engagement fort euh j'ai qui
qui me semble être de nature en tout cas
dans beaucoup de communes à faciliter ou
à permettre la mise en œuvre d'une
réforme paisible euh des des rismes
scolaires quand je dis paisible
ça pas dire tout le monde sera euh euh
heureux immédiatement mais là encore euh
on sait très bien de toute façon que
quand on veut changer les choses et en
plus à l'école c'est quand même euh
peut-être plus difficile qu'ailleurs
parce que on est tous d'une manière ou
d'une autre concernés par ce qui se
passe à l'école
h sur
euh intervention de Monsieur Husson sur
les regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux
multicit ce qui je comprends ce ce point
là qui est un point
euh tout à fait important c'est pour ça
que j'ai cherché moi les moyens de
mutualiser on m'a posé cette question et
y compris ici cantine ici école cette
commune et nos enfants se
répartissent moi je me suis poser la
question et pas seulement pour alléger
les coups c'est comment à travers la
libération d'une après-midi on répond à
cette situation où parce qu'on a un
regroupement sur un seul site voire sur
plusieurs sites d'activités qui sont des
activités
qui correspondent à un intérêt de
plusieurs communes on on arrive à à à
avoir des solutions adapté à ces
réalités là donc je crois qu'on y arrive
par le décret cela autant dit moi je je
nous ferons preuve de discernement euh
vraiment et moi je je dirais pas écoutez
là c saut parce que à la ligne près au
détail près des SEP mè qu'on travailler
chercher une solution et eu le sentiment
de d'être dans les clous des cinq
matinées par exemple l'aurait trouvé
mais à la virgule prês ça ne collerait
pas avec le le décret nous ferons preuve
de discernement et c'est aussi ce que
j'ai demandé aux recteurs qui sont
parfaitement disponible donc nous
regarderons là et c'est pour ça que la
situation de l'xou est intéressante ce
que vous avez évoqué parce que
là il y aura une évaluation parce que je
comprends que d'ailleurs
l'xou discute avec nous faisait ça
depuis longtemps pourrait mettre en
œuvre des dispositions en lien avec les
expérimentations permises parmi le
nouveau décret donc sera l'objet d'une
évaluation comme toutes les communes au
bout de 3 ans et après nous déciderons
de la de la prolongation ou pas si au
terme de l'évaluation on se rend compte
qu'on a des expérimentation qui ont un
effet radicalement contraire à
l'objectif recherch ch bah elles seront
remises en cause mais euh l'objectif de
de de de de cette ces expérimentations
c'est qu'elles puissent justement être
évaluer et permettre derrière leur
prolongation dès lors qu'ell respondent
aux intérêts des
enfants je je redis que le projet de
circulaire intègre c'est dommage que
vous ne l' peut-être mais plusieurs
d'entre vous doivent s'ils sont membres
du CSE l'ont peut-être reçu puisque nous
avons transmis au
CSE le projet de décret circulaire comme
document on peut l'envoyer je pense au
membbres de la mission comme document de
travail si vous le souhaitez mais ça
n'est qu'un projet hein je je le veux
dire parce que tant qu'il est pas validé
euh
prenez-le si vous voulez je moi j'avais
pas de de difficulté à faire si on le
prend comme un projet c'est que faut pas
le faire circuler après derrière comme
le texte qui va être définitif donc ce
que je vous promets ce que je vous
promets c'est qu'après le CS la semaine
prochaine je vous transmets
immédiatement le texte de cette
circulaire sur sur le fond d'amorçage
j'en ai dit un
mot monsieur le
gendre qui a évoqué les là encore les
cinq matinées les remarques euh d'une
psychologue chronobiologiste qui
émettait des des des des des des
critique
bon je vous dis aujourd'hui nous
travaillons sur les bases
euh oui oui oui oui non mais je je
j'entends mais je nous travaillons nous
sur les bases de de travaux qui sont
aussi ceux je le redis de l'Académie
pharmacie l'Académie de médecine mais
sans contester la qualité de ses travaux
euh elle c'est vrai que dès lors qu'on
fait un temps qui va au-delà des 5h3 qui
peut aller à 6h parce qu'on concentre
sur une après-midi on a on peut avoir
aussi des des remarques qui nous sont
faites le principe pour moi c'est les
les les cinq matinées les aides
financières je je je les ai dit vous
avez évoqué le temps de l'enfant et et
et et l'organisation finalement aussi de
euh du calendrier scolaire sur sur
l'année avec des possibilités donc
d'expérimenté rétrécissement en quelque
sorte des des des vacances scolaires
sera soumis donc à l'accord des recteur
donc à évaluation et validation mais
nous intégrons là une dimension tout à
fait nouvelle qui euh existait
auparavant sous forme d'expérimentation
depuis je crois 1990 a été remis en
cause par la réforme d'Arcos va être
réintroduite et qui va dans le sens de
ce nombre de demandes
de professeurs de parents d'élèves qui
peuvent le souhaiter aujourd'hui et qui
qui pourront voir leur souhait en tout
cas expérimenter dans leur commune si
évidemment il y a consensus autour de de
cela sur ce qu'a dit
euh
h madame Michel je crois avoir répondu
sur le le respect de la loi
euh eu égard à à ce qui peut être initié
ailleurs
B je je trouve que le climat
euh ça pèse voilà euh en tout cas je le
souhaite et moi je fais je pose les
actes pour parce que
euh je l'école euh mérite euh autour
d'elle un climat apaisé pour qu'en son
sain il y ait un climat apaisé parce que
c'est trop facile de vouloir que les
enfants
soient instruits éduqués dans les
meilleures conditions euh dans un climat
euh le plus apaisé qu' soit si par
ailleurs autour tout le monde s'écharpe
euh euh d'une décide d'ouvrir ou de ne
pas ouvrir selon ses propres convictions
non il y a des règles et le message qui
doit être celui de la du collectif que
nous sommes d'élus ou
euh c'est c'est d'avoir un message
pédagogique à garde de nos concitoyens
vous savez il y avait des une étude bon
en l'occurrence euh dans unble de que je
vous invite à prendre avec beaucoup de
précaution parce qu'elle ne correspond
pas tout à fait aux travaux que nous
nous avons fait sur les situation de de
harcèlement ou euh d'agressivité à
l'égard des directeurs d'école je dis ça
pourquoi parce que l'Observatoire
International des des violences
scolaires a dit que l'auteur de cette
étude n'était pas chercheur auprès de
l'Observatoire bon mais peu importe nous
avons nous dans le cadre de la
Délégation interministérielle qui avait
été mise en place par Monsieur chattel
sur de prévention de lutte contre les
violences scolaires nous avons aussi un
certain nombre d'instruments de mesure
sur le fait que des directeurs d'école
peuvent parfois être en situation d'être
insulté voire même bousculé euh voir
frappé P ce qui existe heureusement dans
que 02 % des cas par des des parents
d'élèves dans des situations très
conflictuelles et on constate donc que
évidemment l'école n'est pas à l'abri de
des violences de l'extérieur des
inégalités de l'extérieur de la
brutalité qui peut être celle aussi de
la vie notamment en période de crise
mais il nous revient dans ce moment-là
au moment où on parle d'organiser le
temps scolaire au profit des enfants de
nous ne pas finalement
importer dans l'école euh ce qui peut
être la pré parfois du débat politique
allant jusqu'à dire non je n'ouvrirai
pas euh non il n'y aura pas la la loi ne
s'appliquera pas chez moi ça ça je le
dis parce que je pense que la dimension
pédagogique ou éducative de ce message
est totalement contreproductive pour le
coup à l'endroit de toutes celles et
ceux euh enfants adolescents jeunes
adultes ou adultes qui euh apprennent ou
transmettent ou travaillent à l'école
donc ça c'est mon message personnel de
ministre de l'Éducation donc moi je
travaillerai à l'apaisement ce que
monsieur gatolin a dit sur jeune viler
sachez que monsieur le sénateur nous
avons aujourd'hui le projet de jeun
Villier entre les mains que nous y
travaillons euh et que nous y
travaillons à à trouver des des des
solutions qui soient adapté à la parti
aux problématiques de la ville de jeun
Villier c'est comme le cas de pour dire
voilà on travaille on travaille avec de
de bons espoirs de succès sur cette
ville comme beaucoup d'autres et euh et
bon il y a pas de de de cas
insurmontable hein dans honnêtement je
je n'en connais pas jusqu'ici
d'insurmontable alors en disant ça je
prends des risques je vois bien parce
que ça va être une parce que je je tente
le diable mais mais euh mais je je je
crois pas qu'il y ait de sujet
insurmontable voilà sur
Madame Gillot euh là
encore sur le regroupement sur une
demi-journée
ce sont des projets expérimentaux qui
sont soumis à l'évaluation et
l'évaluation
sérieuse et donc oui et autorisation des
des rectorats et des autorités
académiques nous n'allons
pas le le décret qui complète le décret
initial est pas là juste pour faire
passer la réforme coûte que coûte en
remettant en cause les principes de
cette réforme en clair c'était pas une
manière de réintroduire les 4 jours pour
d'une manière déguisée pour qu' en clair
on ait une forme de simulacre de réforme
qui aurait été remis en cause par un
décret complémentaire il y aura bien sur
ces expérimentations autorisation
évaluation au bout de 3 ans et recherche
évidemment c'est pour ça que j'ai
rappelé les C matinées recherche de
l'intérêt de l'enfant comme le principe
majeur sur le calendrier annuel je vous
rappelle que cela exista depuis 90 la
possib ilité d'aller mordre en quelque
sorte ou empiéter sur sur les vacances
scolaires moi je trouve que c'est
intéressant de pouvoir le faire là
encore quand ça répond à un projet
pédagogique et quand il y a mobilisation
des ressources autour de ce projet et et
consensus autour de ce projet ce qui me
paraît
être évident sur ce qu'a pu dire Madame
Lagarde je cherche ma petite fiche
est-ce que sauf à ce que j'ai déjà
répondu à tout euh et
madame la Présidente pour ces questions
sèches qui étaient
sèches j'ai mais qui étent direct quoi
voilà sur j'aiessayie de répondre sur la
durée du
weekend plus long pour vous
dire ma préférence et en même temps le
fait que je le redis le principe des
cinq matinées soi maintenu et pour moi
l'acquis fondamental et
après nous avons déjà 94 % des communes
qui avaient validé ou étent en cours de
validation une organisation du temps
scolaire il en restait six sur ces six
le nouveau décret déverrouille une
multitude de situations le nouveau
décret complémentaire au premier peut
amener à rediscuter une partie des 94
mais je pense que nous serons dans des
proportions qui resteront modestes au
regard du du du du du du volume euh euh
moi je je je ne je je je resterai
évidemment très attentif à la façon dont
les recteurs vont vont me remonter les
les les les les retours qu'ils ont des
mairies sur sur ce point j'entendais
monsieur avait évoqué le fait que ce
nouveau décret finalement a pu mettre un
peu de de confusion supplémentaire là où
il voulait clarifier
bon je reconnais que c'est c'est c'est
pas simple puisqu'on est dans un
environnement médiatique où où si on
n'arrive pas à toucher tout le le monde
que on entend dire que le ministre a
pris un nouveau décret faut supposer que
il soit restitué correctement dans tous
les médias c'est vrai que c'est
difficile et compris pour les
journalistes de pouvoir restituer
l'essens même d'un texte en quelques
lignes quelques mots et cetera c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'abord j'ai
demandé à mes services de prendre
contact directement avec les maires
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite j'entends mettre en œuvre une
grande campagne publique d'information
sur la prochaine rentrée scolaire et les
rythmes qui assume la position du
Gouvernement sur cette réforme des
rythmes c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'écrirai à tous les parents d'élèves du
premier degré pour leur dire ce qui se
passera à la rentrée prochaine et et que
j'entends bien que les gouvernement
disent clairement aux élus qui ont à
organiser le temps périscolaire même si
je le dis c'est facultatif pour
eux-mêmes et pour les enfants mais qu' y
a pas beaucoup d'élus qui se
désintéressent fondamentalement du
tempéré scolaire donc je comprends que
queji c'est facultatif il dit c'est
facultatif mais bon euh si je m'en
désintéresse je me désintéresse quand
même les enfants de ma propre commune
c'est quand même dommage et ce c'est pas
dans l'idée que je me fais de mon mon
mandat donc effectivement il s'implique
mais j'entends leur parler à eux comme
j'entends parler évidemment au
professeurs qui m'interpelle et aux
parents d'élèves à qui j'écrirai
directement et et et et pour les
informer de la situation euh je le redis
l'expérimentation euh elle court jus
pendant 3 ans 3 ans évaluation à partir
d'évaluation prolongation euh dès lors
que on aura constaté que ça marche et et
si celui ou celle et j'espère un jour
celle puisquil n'y a jamais eu une
ministre de l'éducation nationale vous
rendez
compte jamais une jamais non mais jamais
tu es quand même non mais je je voilà
dans une profession 80 % des professeurs
des écoles sont des femmes dans le
second degré on doit être à des
proportions qui sont quoi 60 % il n'y a
jamais une ministre de l'éducation
nationale j'ai en découvrant ça donc je
souhaite que ce soit celle qui me
succède peut-être dans 3 ans ou si je ne
suis plus là qui décidera à ce moment-là
si certain nom des dispositions doivent
être évoluer dans dans le cadre
réglementaire
voilà monsieur le ministre je vous aveis
demandé est-ce que vous avez déjà défini
des critères par rapport à l'
l'évaluation que vous avez faire pour le
au bout des 3 ans les critères ils sont
ceux que nous avons retenu sur l'intérêt
qui est celui de l'enfant en terme de
rythme les bénéfices que nous serons en
capacité de de commencer à mesurer sur
le décrochage les apprentissages
fondamentaux les résultats en 6e on
commencera à avoir des des des
instruments qui nous permettront avec
nos nos nos nos mais oui les rythmes
scolaires la fatigue le climat oui oui
le climat aussi mais mais nous aurons là
des des des des sombre de critères à
partir desquels évaluer la réussite de
ces projets merci à vous en tout cas
pardon d'avoir été un peu long merci
Monsieur le Ministre juste concernant la
circulaire qui n'est qu'une proposition
pour l'instant il nous serait agréable à
Madame madame le rapporteur et à
moi-même si nous pouvions en avoir une
copie nous nous engageons bien
évidemment toutes les deux à ne pas en
faire usage et à la diffuser de façon
médiatique publi et cetera si vous en
êtes d'accord monsieur le ministre très
bien et Madame Cartron souhaitait encore
vous adresser quelques
mots mot monsieur le ministre alors j'ai
droit à deux mots de la part de la
présidence donc je vais essayer de de
mettre un peu de liant en tout cas moi
je vous remercie par rapport à votre
écoute je crois que c'est ce qui ressort
de de euh de des sénateurs qui sont
présents ce soir euh il y avait un mot
qui avait beaucoup crisper entre
guillemets les sénateurs et les maires
c'était le mot dérogation parce que
chaque fois qu'ils étaient à
l'initiative de proposition
alternative ils étaient soumis à une
dérogation et aujourd'hui vous répondez
par le mot souplesse et je crois que ça
c'est quelque chose qui est entendu et
donc cette souplesse concour à
l'apaisement et donc donc nous
essaierons aussi de faire un un rapport
apaisé merci madame le rapporteur donc
en mot de conclusion monsieur le
ministre vous avez beaucoup parlé
d'apaisement j'ai envie de vous dire
que je pense au nom de la commission que
l'apaisement est déjà là évidemment
grâce à l'assouplissement mais aussi par
votre présence vous n'avez esquivé
aucune question vous avez répondu à à
toutes les questions qui vous ont été
posées vous l'avez fait avec beaucoup de
perspicacité vous n'êtes ministre que
depuis 15 jours mais comme disait comme
on le disait tout à l'heure avec madame
le rapporteur vous avez appris très vite
vous avez pris toute la mesure de la
difficulté de de ce sujet-là qui est un
sujet majeur notamment pour les élus je
voulais vous en remercier au nom de de
l'ensemble de la mission commune
d'information et monsieur le ministre je
j'attendais je croisais les doigts je me
suis dit est-ce qu'il va nous annoncer
effectivement une prise en charge
pérenne
euh telle qu'elle a été demandée par les
uns et les autres vous n'avez pas
répondu par positivement ni négativement
vous semblez nous faire penser que il y
a peut-être des possibilités de
réflexion encore dans ce domainelà alors
pour que votre détermination soit totale
et prenez-le pour un clin d'œil monsieur
le ministre et pas pour comme une
provocation je me permettrai de vous
remettre tout à l'heure 153 pétitions de
des élus de mon département qui
souhaiteraient vraiment que l'aide la la
prise en charge soit pérenne merci
monsieur le
ministre voilà vous l'avez vu et bien
l'échange entre Benoît amont et les
sénateurs lors de cette audition a été
plutôt chaleureux le nouveau ministre de
l'éducation national a ainsi pu préciser
les contours de son décret
complémentaire malgré cela et bien il y
a toujours un fossé qui subsiste entre
les maires les élus locaux qui ne se
sont pas sentis assez accompagnés dans
cette réforme et le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale rappelons que le
décret complémentaire de Benoît amamont
hier et bien n'a pas eu l'aval du
Conseil supérieur de l'éducation conseil
qui rassemble des parents d'élèves et
des représentants de l'éducation
nationale malgré cela et bien ce décret
devrait s'appliquer dès la fin de cette
semaine voilà vous pouvez toujours voir
et revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site sur
publsenat.fr je vous retrouve tout à
l'heure à 16h30 pour l'audition de
Laurent Fabius le ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui va être auditionné sur la
conférence de Paris en 2015 sur le
climat très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaires